Hello, hello everybody.
Hello, I am, I am dead inside because it's 12.30 and at 12.30 I...
I am, I am extra dead inside at 12.30.
I know I had sent messages earlier, but after I was like angry messages, angry rant.
And then I angry ranted myself tired and I was like, sleep time, sleep time.
And I woke up, I'm like, oh, why did I do sleep time?
I could have just, oh, I could have just stayed up.
Why did I do sleep time?
Oh, yeah.
Okay, guys, sorry, I need to wake up a little bit more before we do the special, the special announcement.
Sorry, let me answer this work messages.
Sorry, I can't even talk while I send messages anymore.
I can't multi-task.
Okay, sorry, I can't multi-task while I'm dead inside.
Okay, I need to be more awake to talk about this announcement.
So give me a sec as my brain revs up.
It was like...
And it's like, turn the key on and you're like...
I can't even make a read.
Oh, my God.
Oh, why did I?
Why do I always do nap time?
Nap time is always a mistake, guys.
Oh, my God.
I should never do nap time.
I had to fix my chat.
Give me a second to blow my nose, too.
I'm so...
Okay.
I am okay.
I will be okay, guys.
I will be okay for dad and boy.
I'll be okay for boy.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, before I do an announcement, I need to download the announcement.
Okay.
I thought I was going to be sent the images, but I think they...
I think, like, it's not...
It's okay.
I can use these images.
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah, I'll be fine.
All right.
It's going to be fine.
It might...
Okay.
All right.
Oh, shit.
It's the replay.
Oh, that's how tired I am.
Thank you for letting me know that the replay is on.
All right.
Okay.
I also need to make a tweet after.
I was supposed to draft a tweet before the stream.
Before...
Like, after I make the announcement, I'd be like, post tweet.
But I woke up late today.
So...
I'm so sorry.
But we'll do it all live.
We'll do...
Look, a lot of stuff happened today.
So, obviously, those who were in the pre-chat would know, like, how I was very preoccupied with other things.
No.
I'm tired.
Okay.
So, yeah.
Today started out very messy.
It's still a little messy.
So, like...
So, like, there's still some, like, aftermath messes from it.
So, I'm still a little mentally tired.
But I won't...
I'm trying to move on.
I don't want to talk about it.
It's just...
It's just related to, like, the Twitch rival shit.
But, like, it's all right.
We're fixing it.
Like, I mean, there's really nothing to fix.
I just got to, like, toughen it out and just be like, you're popular now.
You're popular now.
You've made a name for yourself on Twitch.
Like, you just got to deal with it.
But it's just like...
It's just like, you know, stepping out of my bubble and then getting COVID.
That's...
That's how it feels like.
Yeah.
I felt so safe in my little YouTube bubble.
And then I stepped out and then COVID.
Yeah.
So, anyway.
I don't want to talk about it, but it's just...
It's just related to Twitch rivals.
But, like, things are okay.
Nothing's going to be changing about my team.
But I had to deal with a lot of shit earlier today regarding my team.
But, like, I just felt like I can't...
Like, I'm just not going to let it affect me that much.
Anyway.
Special announcements.
Well, one announcement.
I guess you can make it two separate announcements.
Anyway, drum roll.
It's a very important announcement.
We're starting off with an announcement, too.
But, sorry.
Like, I'm, like, interjecting between drum rolls.
So, the very special...
Special, special, special, special announcement that I am making today.
As I prolong this special announcement in anticipation and in suspense.
To make you guys think, what could it be?
What could this special announcement be?
That she couldn't, like...
That she had to make a...
I also, like, I didn't put announcement on the title.
And then my manager was like, Doki, you forgot to put announcement.
And I was like, oh, fuck.
I was so tired because I was dealing with other stuff.
I was like, oh, shit.
That's why I was like, oh, please, guys.
Remember there was an announcement today.
Remembered it.
Guys, I know I forgot to tweet it.
The announcement part.
It's very...
It's actually...
It's actually very, very special.
I was just being a little silly.
I forgot to, like, include it in the title.
But it's there now.
So I was just being...
I was just being a little silly.
Anyway, so...
Oh, wait, is that copyright?
I forgot what song that's from.
It's whatever.
What is this, you might ask?
Well, Curious Dragoon.
I will be officially in as a cosmetic item on the Bandai Sinuality Echo of Ada.
Yes!
So, on the 24th, I will be officially in as a cosmetic item on the Bandai Sinuality Echo of Ada.
I will be doing a special launch stream of the game.
And by checking out the 24th stream...
So you can see there's the back side.
It says Doki Bird.
This is a huge shout-out to Bandai for the sponsor and for including me as a cosmetic item.
And there's dad over here on the side.
And then there's...
Wait, that's the same image I just showed you guys.
And then there's the dragoon over here.
Yeah, they have a little dragoon right over here.
So basically, if you tune in on the January 24th stream, I will be streaming Sinuality Echo of Ada on launch.
I'll also be on the official Bandai YouTube and Twitch channel.
Yes, for the very first time, I shall be multi-streaming on the official Bandai channels.
Plus my own... I don't know if I can... Can I do it on YouTube?
I don't know.
I'll figure it out.
But I'll definitely be on the Bandai Twitch channel.
Because I know you can do YouTube and Twitch.
But I don't know if you can do two YouTube channels.
But I will definitely be on the Bandai official Twitch channel.
And I believe the stream will also be on the official Steam page.
Showcasing the launch of Sinuality Echo of Ada.
So all those Sinuality streams have actually led to this very moment.
Huge shoutout to Bandai.
I'm going to be an official cosmetic item in the game.
That's actually crazy to think about.
Especially a Bandai game.
Like, oh my god.
So you'll be able... I'll be giving out a code.
That you will be able to access to claim the cosmetic.
So you have to tune in on the stream on the 24th.
If you want to claim... If you want a Doki Bird cosmetic.
Of this exact shirt.
So it's... Of course it's an official shirt.
So it is a code.
So you have to be able to claim it.
And oh yeah, it's actually crazy.
It's all thanks to Sandman.
It's all because I decided to play Sandman.
Sorry, Sandland.
It's all because I decided to play...
Sandland.
And it led to this moment.
But yes.
I've known about this for a long time.
And it's honestly been so difficult to keep this a secret from you guys.
Because I've known about it since I was basically sponsored by Bandai to do the Senuality streams.
So it's really great to finally be able to announce it.
And like, you know, it's crazy being officially in a Bandai game of all games.
Our very first experience was being in Rust.
And now we're in a Bandai game.
I'm like, wow.
I mean, it's fucking Bandai.
It's a pretty big deal.
I'm gonna say.
The Aquanium paid off.
Jonatas, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, so that was my big announcement.
I'm super excited.
Like I said, please tune in on the stream on the 24th if you wish to claim the skin.
And I cannot wait to stream the launch date.
I cannot wait to create my waifu again.
Guys, create the same one.
How many times do I have to create the same woman?
Be like, please select another character.
I was like, no.
I know real when I recognize real.
What is this?
Okay, so it is big announced.
Okay, let me make it a pin.
On January 24th, I will be streaming Sin Duality, the launch of Sin Duality Echo of Ada.
And we'll be giving out the code for the official cosmetic Doki Bird item.
Thank you, Bandai.
There we go.
Alright.
That's... yeah!
Oh my gosh, I'm trying to sound more hyped.
But like, I'm so dead inside because of the lack of sleep.
But actually, that's a lie.
I slept a lot.
But like, I'm just mentally tired from this morning.
But yeah!
It's a really cool opportunity.
But like, I'm dead inside from other things.
It's gonna be a long day.
Don't worry.
I have my gamer subs here.
I definitely need it because it's gonna be a long fucking day today.
I'm planning on... so yes.
I know it's a... I'm planning on finishing God of War today.
I looked up God of War 2018 playthrough.
No commentary.
Just to see like, how many hours I have.
This is how I decide if I'm doing like, the final playthrough of something.
I look at it and be like, how much do I have left?
Apparently, it's around 6-ish hours.
Depending on just how... I don't know.
Depending on like, if I can make it.
Like...
It looked like 6 hours.
So like, I think it's possible.
I think it's possible.
Every time.
I always do that to figure out...
To figure out like, how much I have.
I figure out when it's the final part.
So I need... because like, you know.
I don't want to clickbait people and be like, this...
Like, I don't want to be like, do a stream and then suddenly that was the last part of the stream.
But nobody knew about it.
I like to be very vocal on the fact that...
This is the last part, guys!
This is it!
Alright.
Alright, we're doing it live.
We're drafting the tweet right now.
Okay, let me grab...
This...
Let me grab a template of my sponsor stuff.
Alright, there we go.
Alright.
Okay.
We're gonna...
We're doing it all live!
I love doing stuff live.
Okay.
Do I have like, links for it?
No, I don't.
Okay.
Alright.
I just have to be sure I have...
I have like, the link for...
For it and stuff.
But like, for any like, you know, PR link.
Okay, Senuality PR.
And then...
Most likely it'll be 5 PM.
5 PM.
Like, I'm deciding it all live.
Alright, this is how it...
Thank you, at Bandai, for...
Okay, how do I do this?
I will officially be in a Bandai game!
Okay, cause technically I am...
Um...
On January...
On January 24th.
I will be going live.
Live on the official Twitch, Bandai Twitch and YouTube.
Plus my YouTube channel.
Uh...
For the launch of at Senuality.
Um...
You can claim my shirt...
My cosmetic on during the stream.
Alright.
Okay.
I'll be officially...
I will be in a Bandai game.
I'll be going live on the official Bandai...
On the Bandai...
Oh my gosh, I still have words that I need to delete because it's too long.
You can claim my cosmetic during...
On the 20...
During the stream.
Oh my god, it's too long!
It's too long!
The words are too...
Oh wait, I can...
Alright.
Uh...
Oh my gosh, sorry.
I need to like figure out how to make this shorter.
Yeah, but...
When you're...
When...
I want to make it short so it doesn't do like...
Continue more reading.
Continue to read more, you know?
Like that shit.
I'm trying to avoid that.
Alright.
Let me put this image in.
And then this one in.
And then this...
I'll just include all four.
I will be in a Bandai Namco game on January 24th.
Uh...
I will be on...
I'll be streaming...
Okay, streaming...
On the Bandai Twitch...
And YouTube channel...
For the launch of...
You can claim my cosmetic during...
How many more letters do I have to delete?!
Sorry, I'm...
Um...
I'm going through stuff right now.
It's okay, I'm okay.
I'm perfectly fine.
Okay.
I can delete the time.
You guys don't need to know the time.
At 5pm PST.
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, here we go.
I'm making the tweet, guys.
But...
Okay, let's see.
Uh...
I'm making sure everything looks correct, guys.
I'm just making sure everything looks...
Alright, there you go.
Alright.
Boop.
Wait.
And we'll be streaming on...
I'll be streaming on the Bandai Twitch and YouTube channel.
Plus my own channel.
Plus my own for the...
Okay, plus my own for the...
Alright!
Live!
Um, this is how...
This is how sponsorships goes, by the way.
I'm giving you guys, like, a sneak peek of how the sponsorship stuff works.
Like, this is...
That's how real I am, guys.
That's...
This is what goes in my mind when I have to...
You get to look at, like, the behind the scenes of me fucking...
Trying to figure out how to tweet things.
That's a good girl.
Alright.
Okay.
On January 24th, I'll be streaming on the Bandai Twitch and YouTube channel.
Plus my own for the launch of Senuality.
Plus my...
Uh...
And my...
Okay, plus my own for the launch of...
Cleaning my cosmetic during the stream at 5pm PST.
Yay, okay.
Uh...
Buh-buh-buh-buh-buh.
Okay, there you go.
Bam!
There we go.
We did it, guys.
We...
Alright, guys.
Gas this up.
Woo!
We fucking did it!
Alright, here we go.
We did it live.
Alright.
And I did hashtag PR.
So I don't get in trouble with the legal system.
Professional.
You always have to tell...
Let people know.
It's...
It's a fucking...
Uh...
You gotta let people know.
It's sponsored.
Yeah.
We're doing our part.
Now, gas that tweet up.
So people know I did my job.
But yeah, it's a pretty exciting announcement.
It is definitely a very exciting announcement to be officially...
Part of...
A Bandai game.
Even if it's just a cosmetic.
Because, you know, they literally programmed...
They programmed myself into the game.
So...
I'm so happy.
And it's actually...
And it all...
Like...
Like Sand Land basically led to this.
Which is...
Crazy to think about.
Like, the fact that...
Me playing Sand Land...
Like, put myself in...
Bandai's eyes.
Because, like, I was like the top...
I think I was like...
I think, like, what was it?
There was another game that launched around Sand Land's time.
And because of that, like...
I think, like...
I was like...
One of the streamers that...
Actually streamed...
One of the streamers that was super excited about Sand Land.
Because there was another game that launched at the same time.
So, I really appreciate that Bandai, like...
Saw my streams.
And watched my streams.
And were in my chat and stuff.
Like, engaging with my streams too.
And it really means a lot.
And through Sand Land...
They reached out to me and wanted to sponsor me.
And put me in one of their newer games.
One of the other games that was coming out.
Which was Senuality.
So, a huge thank you to Bandai.
And the team in Senuality.
For...
Putting me in their game.
And I really appreciate it.
So, yeah.
You can get your very own shirt.
You can get your...
I better see...
When I play Senuality on the 24th.
I better see you guys fucking wearing my shirt.
Guys, I better see you like...
And I'll still kill you.
But like...
I'm still gonna take your legs.
At least I know they're your legs.
You know?
At least I know they're Dragoon's legs.
But...
So, like...
It's good to know that you're a Dragoon.
No, no.
You can...
You'll unlock it instantly.
Cause it'll be a code...
That'll be giving out during the stream.
So, like...
Anybody can use the code.
But...
The code will be giving out...
On the 24th.
So, anybody can claim the code.
So, you don't have to grind the game out or anything.
You just instantly get it.
Alright!
Alright, let me boot up...
God of War.
So, the last time we left God of War...
Oh, let me plug in my controller.
Wait, no.
I already have my controller plugged in.
Let me swap it to a Playstation controller.
Cause last time we used an Xbox controller.
Oh my gosh, I am slowly waking up now.
I'm actually waking up right now.
Oh my god.
It's gonna be a long fucking day today.
Is this supposed to be...
Is that supposed to be the sound?
Oh no.
Is that...
I don't know.
I'm trying to remember if this was the...
That has to be the Dynasty.
I didn't adjust it yet.
I gotta make sure this is the Dynasty Warrior sound settings.
So, like, I don't have to forget.
Okay.
Dynasty.
I always keep note of the sound settings I have for each game.
If it's a series.
So, I'm gonna change that to Dynasty.
And then...
God of War was 10.08.
Okay.
10.08.
Professional streamer here.
That's how I keep track of the sound.
Like, what the sound is.
No, there's no second announcement.
There's no, like, story update today.
I mean, if you were in pre-chat, you basically got a story update.
But it was an angry story update.
But, like, it's okay.
I'm just tired now.
Alright.
Oh, yes.
It's actually...
It's always been God of War.
It's okay.
The price of going outside...
The price of getting COVID.
Oh my god.
Now I understand, like, why people get into so much drama.
I was like, how do people...
I was just...
I didn't even...
I was just like...
I was like...
What the...
I feel like...
I feel like Twitch always gets into a lot of drama.
And now I understand.
Like, I just...
Like, I put myself out there for, like, two weeks.
And then, suddenly, I'm part of drama.
And I didn't even realize it.
Like...
There's, like, apparently, like, several Twitch dramas going on right now.
And, like...
Like, the fucking...
What was it?
There's the Pirate Software one.
There's Elon Musk versus Asmongold.
There's, like, two other things that happened.
I, like, didn't realize the whole, like...
I don't pay attention to World of Warcraft.
Especially hardcore World of Warcraft.
So, like...
Like, I didn't know what the fuck was going on until it was on my entire Twitter feed.
And I saw, like...
Your people were like...
Jokey, what do you think?
And I was like...
I don't care.
Like...
I'm sorry.
It's not in my jurisdiction.
I legitimately...
I, like, don't care about...
Like, I'm sorry.
I legit...
I, like...
I...
Okay.
Story...
Okay, this is my story time for...
Like...
If it's not...
If it's something that I don't know much about or, like, something I actually...
I don't care.
Like, it's not in my field.
Okay.
Here's why I don't care about World of Warcraft.
Let me...
Okay, here's my story time.
This is why...
I actually received an email.
Okay, Dragunov, you're here.
I did...
I thought it was funny.
But, like...
I received an email.
Like...
And, like...
The email was like...
You talked about Pirate Software in one of his tweets a couple of months ago.
I'm here to advise you to stay out of it.
Like, stay out of it.
And don't associate with Pirate Software.
And then, I'm just like...
I was like...
What the...
Yeah, I don't remember what the fuck that tweet I talked about on stream.
I mean, that man tweets so much.
And, like, all his entire, like, stream persona is to be on the Shorts algorithm and Twitter algorithm.
So, like...
Yeah, of course, one of his tweets showed up and I talked about it.
Because it must have been something...
It must have been something that made me talk about it.
Because that's why I talk about these things.
Like, he said something that made me want to talk about it.
And...
But then, I was like...
But then, like...
I thought it was...
I thought it was so funny.
Because, like...
I don't care.
Yeah.
So...
So, like...
Okay, this is why I don't have much of an opinion about World of Warcraft.
Because my dad used to love World of Warcraft.
And, um...
And he would make me play with him every day.
Um...
Like, when I got home from school.
And...
But then, like, it will all be in Chinese.
So, I had no idea what the fuck was going on.
But, like, he just wanted someone to play with.
But he didn't want to join a guild.
So, he made me play with him.
Until, like...
He got, like, a flying mount.
And then, after...
Because, like, he just grinded until he got a flying mount.
And then, after he got a flying mount, he was like...
I'm done with this game.
And then, after he was done with this game...
I was done with the game.
It was sweet at first.
I had fun at first.
But then, like...
I don't know what's going on.
So, like, I never...
And then, like, I wanted to do other things.
Like...
I didn't...
I didn't want to play World of Warcraft all the time.
I wanted to play other things.
Like...
So, like...
Because of that experience, I've never touched World of Warcraft after that.
So...
That's why I just...
I don't care.
I don't care about what's going on in World of Warcraft.
But, like, the context of the whole drama...
It's actually crazy that the drama was so big, though.
Because I didn't...
Basically, it's called Roachgate.
And, like, it's the whole, like...
I'm not gonna give my opinion on it.
Because, like, that's the whole reason there's drama about it.
Because they're like, do you agree?
I just think, like...
It's just the fact that, like...
He fucking, like, left his team to die.
And then...
And then that's...
That's basically the whole gist of it.
And he just didn't say sorry.
And...
Or took accountability.
The craziest thing, I feel like, is if he actually just said sorry...
Nobody would say anything about this drama.
That's really it.
It just became bigger than it should be.
It's...
It's always ego.
This is what I mean.
I literally came out of my bubble.
I came out of my YouTube bubble.
And it's just egos.
Yeah.
But after all this I thought...
Maybe things were different.
You do not know everything, boy.
No.
But yeah, I'm not here to actually give my opinion who was right and who was wrong.
If like, I just don't say like, even if he thinks he was right or he thinks he was wrong, if he- he just- he didn't have to believe in his apology.
Like...
Like, if he- he knew by not taking accountability it was gonna get into a bigger issue.
It would grow into a bigger thing.
I would have just said sorry, but I wouldn't believe him.
I wouldn't believe I was wrong.
If I was like- if I was in his shoes and I think I was right.
Obviously, I don't know what the fuck- I don't really care in general.
I don't care about World of Warcraft in general because of my terrible- not my terrible experience, but because I'm tired out when I was a kid.
So, I'm in a story.
Can you turn into an animal?
No, you can't.
Can Kratos turn into an- have you ever seen your father turn into an animal, boy?
Don't be stupid.
That's right, I'm a what?
You're a god, boy.
I'm a what?
I'm a god.
Why did you wait so long to tell me?
I had hoped to spare you.
Being a god.
It can be a lifetime of anguish and tragedy.
Because you grew up to be a pussy at first.
That is the curse.
So, I felt like you didn't have the god in you.
What sorts of things can I do?
Can I fly?
Turn invisible?
You try to use magic.
Artaeus, boy, did you not hear me?
Being a god is not what it cuts out to be.
Your mother is dead!
That's the price of being a god.
All right.
Is this why you're schizophrenic?
That's- Thanks, boy.
You already do, laddie.
Your faculty for language is extraordinary for one so young.
Time alone will tell what else you'll become capable of.
So you knew all along.
I did, lad.
But I've known more than my share of gods.
Me too, apparently.
All right.
Yeah, like I said, I don't give opinions on things I don't really care much about.
Or like, it's outside my territory.
I just also think it's very fucking funny that we live in a time and place where we're witnessing Elon Musk fucking having an argument with Asmongold.
I think that's fucking hilarious.
I didn't realize he has the power.
Yeah, we are.
We're fucking gods.
Yeah, we've been doing what we've always been doing.
I was already a god.
I think the craziest part is that I didn't realize he could do that.
But if Elon Musk really, really hates you, he'll take away your check- like your verified check mark.
Like, I'm like, did he pay for that?
I'm just like, that's so petty.
He took away his check mark.
That's insane.
Yeah, yeah, you got that.
Like, I'm like, but like, I thought it was a paid feature.
That is insanely petty.
There's like, you're no longer verified.
Alright, read, boy.
Alright, what else does it say, boy?
Is that it?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I guess we go forward.
Alright, thanks, boy.
Let's open the door!
Wait, we go back inside.
Wait a minute, what?
There's two entrances?
Oh, shit, let's go back inside, boy.
Looks like he still has the check mark.
Yeah, he gave it back after people were like, what the fuck?
That's so petty.
Earth.
This says earth, then what else do we have to do, boy?
Read.
Oh, okay, now do the thing, boy!
That's such a shitty god power.
He's just very, very good at languages.
Like...
That's such- I don't know.
Seems like a shitty god power.
No like, strength or invincibility.
You just know how to read.
He just reads really, really well.
Oh no, he's growing an ego.
It's time to end him.
Oh no, he's gonna become a streamer!
We gotta stop him!
We got it!
His ego is growing!
No!
Don't you mind teaching us some Mandarin?
I need it for red note.
Thank you for the super chat, Gavin.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh shit, sorry for pausing it.
I need to open up my...
Um, super chat area.
Oh yeah, I saw an Akka.
I'm so sorry I didn't read the Akka.
Uh, JL, thank you for the Akka Super!
Thank you, thank you!
Next up, an official appearance as a full skin in a game.
Maybe even an entire character!
JL, thank you for the Akka Super!
Thank you, thank you!
I hope so.
I hope so in the future.
Thank you!
Oh...
How dare he?
How dare he share our knowledge to the world?
It doesn't make us special anymore!
How fucking dare he?
I hope...
Did he die?
I'm pretty sure...
Yeah, whatever happened.
Oh, I fucking knew it.
Yeah, but they deserved it, right?
Are you trying to say gods did something wrong?
Us?
There's no way.
Gods are always right.
That's why we're gods.
We gotta smite him.
Oh!
Oh my god, it's so pretty!
Hello, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Whoa!
It's like when...
Doki had that little bump added to her reference.
So much ego!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Boy, put your hands through this!
Now that you're a god, you'll live!
What the fuck?
What do you mean naturally?
What the fuck does this mean?
Oh yes, of course!
Of course, the floating triple rings as it should be.
Okay, deactivate the vault's defenses.
Quite natural.
How do I deactivate it?
Oh, is there anything here?
I just...
No?
What the fuck yo- It's a puzzle.
I know it's- Oh wait, there's something here.
There's something here.
Oh wait, that's health.
Wait, that's not good.
Oh, is this a maze?
No, it's just one way.
Never mind.
What?
I love puzzles!
Do I shoot this?
Shoot this, boy!
I forgot how to shoot.
Shoot this?
No?
Wait...
I have my- Don't worry, I have another thing.
No?
Okay.
Uh...
Is it here?
No, there's something I have to do.
Come on, Doki.
Use your brain.
You're slowly waking up now.
Doki, you got this.
Your brain has been revved up.
Please, you're supposed to complete this today.
Where is the one?
What?
My brain is so...
Come on!
Brain cell!
Where's the bright green thing?
There's no bright green thing anywhere.
I'm like running around.
Wait, is there a bright green thing in the back?
Back here?
No, there shouldn't be.
Is there any behind the doors?
Okay, no.
Oh god.
I looked at it!
Oh god, okay.
Okay.
I didn't realize that it was right there.
I didn't realize it was on the fucking giant ass ring.
Alright, now we pull.
Alright, I believe in you boy.
Go do the thing.
Now that you're a god, you're practically invincible, right?
That's how it works, right?
Wait, is he coming there with me?
Come on, do it!
Wait, where's my boy?
Fucking pussy, you found out you're a god and now you don't want to do this?
How do you not- oh shit.
Wait, what?
Oh, there's one.
How do you find out you're a god and now you decide to be a fucking coward?
Your boy of mine's gonna be a coward.
How did you get here?
Wait a minute.
Oh?
Is this old wine?
Drink it, Katos.
Become an alcoholic again.
You might as well, you got the dead beat part, right?
Steal it.
Wait, that's me!
Look, son, I'm famous!
It's what I used to do, son.
I basically did the same thing- oh.
I mean, it's not different from before.
Like, I still- I kill things now and I used to kill things.
Like, my boy's not gonna think it's different.
Oh, it's like- Tiara, like, collected different things from the gods- from different gods or different societies.
It's my merch!
Buy my merch!
Why does that say square?
Okay.
That did absolutely nothing.
Oh, okay, now I registered.
A lot of incest.
So it's sort of like- it depends on- I guess- I guess you can say bad?
What?
That's what the Egyptian gods did!
Some people- you guys didn't know that?
It's not like I was lying!
Alright, get over here.
Like, I wasn't lying about that!
I was just saying how it is!
Alright, use your- use your wolf!
Get that wolf in!
Oh shit, no, that's not the one weapon I want to use.
I want to use the sword, honestly.
The sword is so cool.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh my god.
Get over here!
Boy, I can't shoot you over the sound of my fucking coolness!
My testosterone is going up right now!
Oh my god!
I feel so much joy!
Get over here.
Oh yeah, you're right, all the Egyptians did it.
It's not just- it's not just a god, it was just- he doesn't understand, it was just a way of life.
If you weren't- if you weren't being a family member, what were you doing?
Like the old Egyptian people were saying back then.
Alright.
Oh, nice.
Tryna- okay, R1.
Don't keep- it's true!
I'm not- I'm just- I'm just giving you guys a history lesson!
Oh my god, I might actually die from this history lesson.
Give me a sec.
I might die because of history.
It's true, you don't- you're not supposed to say- I'm just educating!
What's wrong with education?
Alright, let's grab some HP because we are gonna die if we don't.
I was too busy reciting history to figure out my health issues.
Wait, aww.
There was like-
Yeah, I remember there was like a gate area that needed this.
But like, which area was it?
Was it here?
Where did I come from?
I came from here, right?
Wait, no, this is different?
I'm lost.
Oh no, this is- I already forgot where I was.
Oh, I legitimately- oh no, there's too many entranceways.
Okay, okay, I came from here, I remember now.
Why is there so many- but then there's like an upstairs!
Oh no, my head hurts.
Oh no, I don't know if I can finish this in six hours now.
Alright, MrBrokenBot, thank you for the superchat, thank you, thank you.
Doki talks about incest while ignoring her son's cry of help.
Guys, I had to give a history lesson.
Boy was interrupting education.
Okay, this way.
I have no idea what this- where this is supposed to take me.
Oh, okay, there's a win area here, too.
Read, boy.
Use your special god powers.
Can't believe it.
That's all he has?
That's so sad.
You were born a god and all you can do is just read a little better.
Like, what's the point?
Alright, let's see.
Oh shit, that's not what I want to do.
Oops.
Uh, there we go.
I raised the f- the worst god power in existence, honestly.
You could have had every- you could have had anything else, boy.
Oh my god, come on, get over here.
Is this not how I grab the wind?
I can't grab it here?
Am I too far?
I guess I am too far.
I thought I could grab it from here.
Can I grab it from down here?
Okay, can I go up with it?
Oh, I can.
Oh my god, boy, I wish- oh my god, that was- Oh, I'm just missing?
Oh, I was like, okay, if my boy was not chicken grabbing onto me, um, then, like, I could have hit it.
I could have been up there faster.
Okay, so I was just missing, then.
Because there was a- there was a thing on the other side, right?
Is this a- oh, it's because I need to time it.
Because, like, I remember on this side, there was another one, too, that I had to use.
I had to time it, I see.
Oh my god, oh, I'm gonna freaking freak out.
I'm- okay, okay.
Okay, I need to time this.
I hate this already.
Oh my god, no, no, no.
Yes!
Okay, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
It's right here.
There we go.
What does that do?
What did I do?
What did I- okay, but what does that do?
I did it, but what?
It looks a little cooler, but what does it do?
Is there another one that I missed out on?
This was the one I did, right?
What did- what did it do?
Is that it?
I made it cooler.
I mean, it does look pretty cool.
I mean, yeah.
It does make it look pretty cool.
I guess on the other side, that this one over here, but like, I feel like- oh no, what?
No!
Fuck, okay, I have to run faster.
I mean, now that I know it's like right here.
Grab it faster.
I didn't know where I was.
I guess I had to go here.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, that was- that was awkward.
Alright, I guess that was it.
Nice.
Well, I guess I do this.
Just because you hate being a god doesn't mean I have more small passages.
Alright.
Oh shit.
Alright, and then we climb up.
What?
Oh, I thought I could climb.
Okay, we go to that.
And then we go here.
Okay.
Sorry, boy.
This is much more important.
Oh, nice.
Yes.
Oh, that's so cute.
They look cute.
They look pretty friendly.
I didn't realize he was dropping important lore.
I just saw a puzzle room.
I was like, oh puzzle.
How was I supposed to know?
I have to do fucking puzzles.
I killed my other family and wear them as my skin now.
So yeah, it's pretty alright.
I came from here, right?
Yeah, I came from here.
So like...
Why are there like two more traps?
Is there like bonus stuff here?
I assume maybe?
Maybe there's like bonus.
Oh, it is bonus!
Okay.
That means there are bonus things to do.
Where the fuck is CRN?
Oh my god, I hate these.
I hate these puzzles.
I have so- oh my god.
Okay.
Uh...
Where's my other- where's my axe?
Where did it go?
Where did my axe go?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it was still attached to the other thing.
Oh, there's the other one.
Okay, we got one of them.
Where's the other two?
It's in here?
The fuck is the other two?
I'm looking up.
Huh?
I thought- I got the CE.
Oh, I hate these puzzles the most.
These puzzles are actually- I'm gonna fucking freak out.
These puzzles are like- Oh my god, I hate these puzzles the most.
Where's Waldo?
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
Oh my god, I'm gonna- I'm gonna break something.
The fact that someone's like, you looked at it.
I'm like, whaaat?
Like, they all have to be in this vicinity.
And it's blue, but everything else is blue too!
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm gonna fucking- oh my god.
Where is it?
My stress level is rising.
Where the fuck is Waldo?
Where is he?
It does not help!
It's like- Boom!
Boom!
Where is it?
Where the fuck is it?
If I look over here, will I see it?
I don't understand.
In the center of the room?
Ow.
What?
Above me?
I can't.
I- Can they be in different rooms?
Or is it just in that one room?
There's no way it's outside.
Has to be like, just that room, right?
Look around the other room.
How do you know they can be in other rooms?
Oh, it can be!
Oh my god!
It can be in other rooms.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I was stuck in that one room.
I did not realize it could be in other rooms.
Okay, we're missing one more letter.
We just need one more letter.
Hello there, big boy.
Okay, one more.
Where's the last one?
N.
The last one is N.
Close by?
The fuck does that mean?
Oh, I hate these puzzles so much.
I remember when they were so easy.
Like, they're literally in your face.
And now they're like, here's 200 million items.
Find the letters.
No, it's N.
It can't be.
Is it really behind these?
I don't see it.
Oh, the other one?
No, it has to be...
This one, right?
Is it here?
Oh shit!
No,
don't make me!
No!
Where am I?!
What the dude
is here?!
There's no way!
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I actually have to...
Oh my god.
Oh,
I'm so sad.
I got confused.
Oh my god.
I hate this.
Okay, I know it was behind this.
It's like, right here.
Or right here.
Oh fuck.
How did I fucking...
Oh my god.
Alright.
There we go.
That was one of them.
Alright.
And then the other one was like...
here.
Alright.
Then where's the last one?
There's the last one in this one, right?
The last one in this one?
Guys, before I go over there, is the last one in this ruin?
Okay.
I will not get squished by them this time.
Alright.
Where is it?
Did I lie to you?
You lied to me?
You guys lied to me?
You guys lied?
Where is it?
I
am on the other side!
Oh my god!
The fuck?
Where is it?
Oh my god.
I died here for nothing.
I actually died there for nothing?
Oh my god!
I hate you guys.
It was on the same side.
Alright, open.
Nice, what did I get?
Was it worth it?
It was one out of the three.
I guess it was worth it.
Oh my god.
Now where am I supposed to go?
I don't know.
I'm like so lost now.
I came back here.
But like...
Where am I supposed to go?
Did I come from here?
No, this is different.
This is a new area, right?
I can't.
Everything is blurring together.
Okay.
This is new.
I don't know.
There's a trap there in front of me.
I wonder what these traps are guarding.
What will I find out now?
I don't know.
I haven't been here, right?
This is new.
I can never tell.
I'm so confused.
Yeah, this has to be new.
Wait, I have been?
Oh, wait.
This is where I've been.
Ow.
Sorry.
I fucked up.
But how did I do this?
I don't remember how I did this.
I don't remember.
How did I do this?
Oh, it's right here.
Okay.
Wait, am I stuck?
No.
I can do this.
Yeah.
I remembered.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm so lost.
I'm so fucking lost.
I can't remember where I've been anymore.
They all look the same.
Everything looks the same.
All these traps.
I've played these games before.
Alright.
Wait, have I been here?
Okay.
Is this new?
Wait a minute.
What?
I just went backwards.
I'm back here.
I'm so lost.
Oh my god.
My yellow paint is
in...
Have I been here?
Oh my god.
I ran around in a circle.
Okay.
Maybe it's like here somewhere.
Right?
Okay, I went through that.
What was over here?
What was over here again?
Okay, so...
This is the wolf puzzle.
Oh wait, there's heals here.
I don't need the heals though.
Oh, I needed the wind for that!
Okay.
Boy, I figured it out.
I need wind.
Oh my god.
I forgot to open the door!
I did it.
Okay.
Where did I leave the wind?
Where did the wind go?
Wait, where did the wind go?
Is it back up here?
Oh, it is.
Oh shit.
I did not mean to use my hands.
What the...
Oh shit.
Wait, that's cool.
Wait, I can do that?
Is this what gamers call parry?
Oh my god.
Is this what it's like to parry?
Alright.
Oh wait, I forgot I have a boy to shoot them.
Baseball!
Alright, come on boy.
Shoot your arrow!
Shoot it!
Be useful, boy!
Continue to be useful.
Nice, alright.
Now I need to...
I guess I'll put it in here.
And I'll lower it.
Yeah!
Why did I put it side by side?
Don't forget my wife's what?
Okay, sorry, I don't know what you're talking about.
I only have one weapon.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
The only reason I was stuck is because I forgot I had...
I forgot about the door right here.
I forgot!
It's because I died!
Of course I forgot!
I fucking died!
Oh shit.
You won with nature.
What is it doing?
Which one?
Get the green wire!
Use your god power!
Your most useless god power out there.
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
Wait, what?
Wait,
how do I make him shift?
Oh shit!
Oh fuck!
I didn't know!
I'm panicking!
I put it in the wrong one!
Oh fuck!
I guess I'll just...
I guess I'll drown.
I put it in the wrong order, guys.
It was an accident.
I was freaking out.
Guys, I was so confused!
No, I didn't mean to die in the middle!
Oh guys, I was freaking out.
Guys, I was freaking out.
I didn't know I could...
The boy could do this without my help, guys!
I legitimately thought...
I thought I could...
I didn't know, I thought...
Oh fuck, okay.
The middle!
Okay.
This is it, I can do this.
I can fix this.
No!
I didn't realize I could do more.
I thought the boy was gonna do this for me.
I was gonna be like...
Yippee, boy!
You're gonna...
Boy, you're gonna fucking...
Oh wait, what the fuck am I doing?
Oh my god.
They actually just put it in order for me.
Oh my god, I fucked it up.
I already fucked it up.
Oh my god, I am panicking.
I am panicking.
I already fucked it up.
I didn't know.
I was panicking.
Okay.
Alright.
Middle.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I gotta keep pulling.
Wait, how the fuck do I fix this?
Oh!
Oh my god, okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
And then...
Oh no, no, please.
Please don't do this.
I'm panicking again, boy.
Please.
Okay.
No!
I was so close!
I keep panicking.
I don't do well at this.
I don't do...
I...
It all makes sense in my head.
But I just can't...
I just can't be like...
Middle.
The middle boy.
Just keep putting it in the middle.
Oh my god.
Okay, there you go, there you go, there you go.
I figured it out.
Oh my god, why is it...
Why is it faster?
I felt like I had more time before when I was panicking, boy.
Yes, I know.
Why couldn't he do this himself?
I don't understand.
Why am I the one that's...
Oh my god.
Okay, the middle.
There we go.
We did it.
Wait, is that not it?
That's not it?
What is this?
This is not the son?
No?
Wait, what?
Oh shit!
Oh, I fucking beat him!
I fucking beat him!
I'm so dumb!
I thought it had to be...
Okay, I'm dumb.
I thought...
I thought it meant like...
They had to be at the bottom.
And I realized, oh, it has to be at the top.
Guys, my brain is not awake yet.
My brain is not awake.
Oh my god.
Do I have to tell you everything?
You became a god and you became more stupid.
Like, how is that possible?
How did you become more stupid knowing you're a god?
It's not working.
Guess I died then.
Alright.
Well, it worked.
Wait, he got rid of her.
But that's your mom's knife.
That's your mom's knife.
That's your mom's knife though.
That was your last connection to her.
Oh no.
He became a god and now...
Now he's getting rid of his mortal possessions.
Retrieve the black rune.
Is that the black rune?
Guys, I'm starting to not think we're gonna finish this game today.
There it is.
We've got it.
I'm slowly starting to think.
After that puzzle's performance, I don't think my brain is ready to finish this game today.
Oh, he gets the god knife.
You are a man now, my son.
Now that you know you're a god.
Oh shit, yes.
No, what?
No, yeah.
You shall never be a man.
We are boys.
Boy, do not...
Do not...
Do not become one of the gods that fuck animals, boy.
We have to be better.
Or incest.
We gotta be better, boy.
Nice.
Yeah, yippee!
I did it.
My little boy is growing up to still be a boy.
What?
Oh, I just can't read.
What the fuck?
It's like, on my skin.
Why is it always...
Oh my god.
It's fucking...
Oh no, oh it's fire.
Okay, where's my...
Why is it always fucking...
Trolls!
It's always trolls!
When is it not trolls?
Oh shit.
It's always trolls.
Wait, how the fuck do I...
Oh wait, what?
Oh wait, maybe I kill this guy.
Maybe I kill him.
I'm so confused, cause like, one is taking damage and the other one isn't.
Why is it always trolls?
Why can't it be something different?
Oh shit.
Oh my god, this is not fair.
It's literally 2 to 1, it's not fair.
It's so not fair.
Oh my god, where's my axe?
Where is...
Oh my god!
I hate being confused!
Okay.
Alright, nice, we did it.
Rachel confusion.
Mawflame has no storage.
Generate through the used upgrade.
Oh nice, I get to upgrade my Blade of Chaos.
I'm confused and I did one die with one HP.
Jesus Christ.
Nice, we did it.
How do I leave?
Oh, okay.
Now it gives me the fucking checkpoint.
The waypoint.
Alright.
You won't like it when I'm confused.
Boy Reid.
Yay, we're going back home now.
It's always trolls.
Why can't I fight something different?
Oh, it's wine.
Boy.
You might be like 12.
But it's time to get drunk.
I'm a good father.
It's just like this troll.
You swag, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
What?
To be fair, back in the ancient times, they used to drink a lot more at a younger age.
Eddie, they're European, right?
Makes sense, technically.
Smells like rotten eggs.
Is it still good?
It's a European thing.
I like how he just chucks it away.
Oh my god, we're bonding.
I'm finally bonding with my son.
It only took like 13 years and a lot of killing.
And my son almost dying because I never told him he was a god until now.
Because your mom was pretty hot.
Ha!
Sure, boy.
Just lie.
I told you guys.
Even if you don't believe it, just lie.
Boom.
I mean,
like...
I feel like nothing has changed since he learned about being a god.
If anything, he's become more stupid.
Oh no, I fucking...
Oh no, he's gonna become a streamer, guys.
Oh no.
His ego, guys.
Oh no, his ego is growing in record speed, guys.
I fucked up.
Now he's gonna become a streamer.
Oh no.
No, boy.
Please.
Be the artist.
Be the dancer artist you wanted to be before.
I won't judge you anymore.
Go be an artist, boy.
Okay.
I think it's this way, right?
I'll just follow the...
I'll just follow the yellow hat.
Here we go.
Up we go.
I'm god and proud.
Friends?
What friends?
We're gonna die alone.
Oh boy, I'm sorry to tell you this, but we're dying alone.
That's why your mother's dead.
What?
See?
This is what happens to you if you don't become a man.
Damn.
Woah!
You got roasted by a 12-year-old.
Are you okay?
Arteus, he fucking upgraded your bow for you.
Oh no, he's gonna cry.
Have you ever seen a dwarf cry?
Look at him.
He's holding back his tears.
Arteus, that's a little...
Woah, Arteus, that's a little...
That's a little fucked up, bro.
Alright, we can finally upgrade our chaos...
Blaze of Chaos.
Oh, he's crashing out.
No, he's absolutely crashing out.
And then...
Can I get the... No, I can't.
What about the bow?
Oh no.
Alright.
I think he's gonna spit on your bow, but that's alright.
Not my problem.
Never yell at the help!
They can spit on your things.
Can I upgrade Axe Palmer?
I feel like...
I just feel like upgrading these don't matter.
I feel like I can just find better items.
Alright.
Is there anything else I can...
No, this was the best one I have.
Momento from...
Wait, Talisman of Concentrated Valley.
I should get that.
Defense.
Oh, wait.
Luck 12.
Actually, I'll keep this.
I keep luck of ages.
He has a name!
What, is he a god?
I don't think so.
Sorry, I only acknowledge gods in this.
I only acknowledge the gods.
Alright, let's see.
I'm just gonna upgrade everything about the Blade of Chaos.
And then we'll get Blade of Chaos maxed up.
And then we'll give our boy some of the magic.
We're gonna max his magic up.
Holy shit!
I have so much XP.
Alright.
And I've got this.
And then we'll upgrade our axe.
Yes!
I feel like switching stances is gonna confuse the shit out of me.
I feel like I'm gonna be more confused if I swap things up.
Okay, I got this.
There we go.
Alright, let's go!
Oh, nope.
Nope, nope, that's the wrong one!
Give me a sec.
No!
Why is it trolls again?!
Why is it always trolls?!
Please!
I'm so...
I'm so fucking tired of trolls!
Oh my god!
I'm gonna fucking die!
Surprise!
Trolls!
I'm so tired of all these trolls and my fucking elo.
It's just like magic.
I'm so tired of trolls!
It's always trolls!
Oh, shit!
Firewolves!
Wait, what?
Is this Jenny?
Oh my god.
Get outta here!
That's right.
I'm unlocking you.
Alright, nice.
We did it.
This is a troll too.
Thank you.
Alright, we gotta go this way.
Oh my god.
We should just kill our trolls, honestly.
Alright, up we go.
Woah!
Mortal opinion matters, Artanis!
Oh my god!
Guys, I love all mortals, guys.
His opinion does not speak for me.
I love all mortals.
I...
Wait, where did my other weapon go?
Oh, there it is.
You absolutely did.
Yeah, I have mortal friends, guys.
Sorry, guys.
He did not get that from me.
Sorry, his mortal racism did not come from me, guys.
I love all mortals.
I even fucked a mortal and produced him as my son!
I married a mortal.
What?
That she wasn't a god?
She was hot and not my sister.
It's the little things, boy.
You don't understand.
She wasn't my sister and that's already an improvement for all guys.
I don't know.
I can't see anything.
I hate this lightning.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
There's so many things behind me!
You gotta be specific!
Everything is behind me!
There's 200 enemies!
Alright, there we go.
We're fine.
Okay, nice.
Did we kill them all?
We did it!
Yippee!
We killed them all!
Turn around!
Okay.
Whoa!
Oh, that's a god you're talking to!
Okay, it's not everything is about Odin.
Oh my god.
Bro, calm down.
Not everybody is out to get you.
Okay, we go back this way.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Wait.
How do I get to the other side?
Wait a minute.
Do I have to go that way?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Can you tell Doki what happened to his last moral famine and about why Kratos is covered in ash?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Look, when you think about Norse God, who the fuck remembers Magni?
You stupid little boy.
No one.
That's why he's dead.
We're not here to worry about the D tier gods, little boy.
We're here to worry about the A gods.
The A tier gods.
The S tier gods.
Nobody's gonna be like, oh man, my favorite god in Norse mythology was Magni.
Magni who?
I didn't even know Thor fucks.
I didn't even know he had a kid.
Magni's not in Marvel Rivals exactly.
Magni's my Norse.
Oh shit.
That's a fucking lie.
Well, at least we know who's not the favorite son.
Oh.
Oh no.
Oh
no.
What the fuck?
Haven't you been teaching me to kill?
Oh no.
How did he just suddenly become a sociopath?
Did you put your...
Did you put your name in the fire?
I don't understand.
How did he just suddenly become a sociopath?
He was literally...
He was a little bitch two hours ago.
What happened?
Just suddenly being told he's a god and then he's like, now I have zero empathy.
Holy shit.
What the fuck happened to you?
That's crazy.
Literally it was just like, he had empathy like what happened?
Like...
Alright, let's get rid of these little guys.
Like
he couldn't even kill a fucking bear in the beginning.
I'm pretty sure like two weeks past.
Two weeks past since the last time since we started the game.
There's no...
Like what happened within two weeks?
Star syndrome, kid.
It's not like gods are immortal either.
They grow up so fast.
Don't they, Doki?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I will do only what is necessary.
And I'll help.
No.
Which way?
This way.
Plenty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm sending you this email to say you shouldn't collab with Arceus.
You shouldn't interact with his content.
He is toxic since he learned to be a god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god, maybe you're right.
Something's changed.
Something's fucking changed.
Wait, a new way out?
Oh, thank god.
Thank god there was the yellow paint.
I got a little scared.
I was like, new way?
What do you mean new way?
Where is the new way?
Wait, is he five?
Okay, no.
I can use this then.
God, I love... Oh shit!
What happened to my HP?
Wait a minute.
Wait, actually what happened to my HP?
Oh shit, oh shit.
Okay, I don't know what happened to my HP, but this is concerning.
I'm about to get mad soon.
Okay.
Okay, don't worry.
Just use your arrows, boy!
Just use your arrows!
That's right, do your thing!
Please, he's one HP, boy.
Please.
He's actually one HP, okay.
Oh god, I'm one HP.
I'm one HP, please.
Somebody drop HP right now!
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, this is bad.
This is very bad.
This is very, very, very bad.
Oh god.
Oh, come on.
There has to be...
Come on, boy, this is it.
This is your time to shine!
You're always yelling about how you're a god, dad!
This is your time to shine, boy!
Okay, nice, nice.
He's almost dead.
This is it.
I just need you to do the thing.
Alright.
I forgot I can do this.
Please, boy.
Use your arrows.
Boy, use your arrows!
Why aren't you shooting your arrows?!
Oh my god!
Okay, there we go.
There we go.
He doesn't shoot his arrows!
I don't know what's going on!
He's so scared!
He's just looking!
Like, what is he doing?!
What?!
That was on purpose?!
Boy!
I will slap you!
I will fucking...
I will fucking slap you, you little shit!
Oh my god!
I thought...
I legitimately thought...
I thought it was my game bugging out, but he was actually being a little fucking shit!
Oh my god!
Bro thinks he's high, elo.
I'm gonna slap this boy!
In-game, guys.
In-game.
I do not endorse slapping, but like, some boys deserve it!
It should be fire, right?
Yeah.
I'm getting my belt of chaos.
I'm getting it, elo.
This is what it's for now.
Where are the health gems?
I told you to shoot the guy, but you didn't shoot him.
What do you mean?
What do you mean you did everything?
I gave you one and I said shoot!
Shoot the arrows!
You used the blades to kill one.
Who else did you kill before Magma?
Do you see me happy?
Can you not tell I'm fucking depressed, boy?
Have you ever seen me smile?
Have you seen me smile?
Fine.
Come here.
Guess what?
I know everything I need to know now.
I have nothing left to learn.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Why did I listen to a witch?
That's why you should never listen to witches.
Never.
Nothing ever comes good.
We should've just burned all witches.
This is why we burn witches, boy.
Nothing ever good comes from listening to one of them.
Should've just let him die.
I could make another boy.
Oh no.
I can't.
I'm too scared.
I am- oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, I had to use the rage.
I got scared.
I legitimately- oh my god.
I'm gonna punch you out from the sky.
Oh shit, this is not what I want.
I had to use the rage.
I was worried I was gonna fucking die from lack of HP.
Oh, now you're gonna help out, huh?
Now you wanna help?
Fucking right.
He's dead.
That's how it goes.
Okay, let's...
Yo!
Pew!
Alright, and then...
We do this...
and...
Wind!
What did that do?
Nothing.
Alright, cool.
You know, I felt like it would've done more.
What the fuck did that do?
Did it not do anything?
I love nothing!
Oh boy, what's up there?
Oh, okay.
Went up.
See, there's money here.
Is there anything upstairs?
Hello?
Anything up here?
I shouldn't waste those.
I feel like I'm always begging for heals.
Read, boy!
Okay.
You're the one thing your power has.
This?
Did I wake him?
Oh.
Oh, I could've saved that.
I could've saved that.
Oh my...
Fucking Chorus!
Oh my God, guys!
Guess what else we have to fucking fight?
A goddamn troll!
Oh my God!
Wow!
I'm so surprised it's another troll!
It's a...
It's a fucking troll!
Wow!
Oh my God!
I fucking knew it!
Wow!
Who would've thought?
I'm gonna fight another fucking troll!
Who would've fucking thought?
Oh shit, I might die from this troll, though.
Oh no.
No, no, no!
Why am I using this?
Bye.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Oh my God, from 1 HP to 0 I'm so fucked.
Fuck.
Please, he's 1 HP!
He's 1 HP!
Nice.
Goodbye, troll!
Oh my God!
I might die from a fucking minion at this point, though.
Okay, there is a high chance I might die to a minion.
Oh no, no, no!
No!
Oh my God, do I at least get...
Do I at least get the troll kill?
Are you seri...
Oh, I did!
I don't get the items from the troll?!
Oh my God.
I don't even get the items.
I don't even get the special items from the troll!
I actually got the 9!
Oh my God, it's so bullshit.
Oh, I hope it's not something important.
I hope it's not something important, guys.
What do I do with this?
Like, can I pick it up?
What?
What do I do?
Oh, if it doesn't have the win, I can pick it up?
Oh, okay.
I didn't know that.
Alright, I'll just transfer the win here then.
Alright.
I feel like...
Can I transfer it?
Wait, how do I drop it?
Wait a minute, how do I drop...
Wait a minute, how do I drop this thing?
Um...
Oh, it's circle.
Okay.
It didn't tell me how, so I got really confused.
Do I put it here?
And then, I guess I put it here.
And can I do it from here?
Is it too far?
No, right?
It shouldn't be too far, right?
Alright, there we go.
Yay!
Puzzles!
Nice, we did it.
Easy.
Easiest puzzles in my fucking life.
What did I get?
Heavy runic attack.
Burn, stun...
Uh...
Fuck it.
More burn is nice.
Alright, let's go.
Let's go, boy.
Yay!
I'm so smart, guys.
It's not like it took me a while to figure that out.
Oh.
Alright, cool.
What am I supposed to do?
Am I supposed to hurt people?
What if I just pull you in?
Get over here.
Oh, that's actually sick.
Wow.
Okay.
Alright, Mr. Fucking Smartass.
That was cool.
Boy.
That was fucking cool.
Alright.
Give your old man some goddamn credit.
What does it say?
Read, boy.
Find a location from the scrolls?
A sequel is mine.
I shall one day...
Maybe one day I'll find that.
One day.
Damien, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Artreus is peak motherless behavior.
Yeah, he definitely has mommy issues right now.
But it's like hitting him hard right now.
What?
I...
Okay.
Wow.
Guess who has to deal with that shit?
Okay.
Okay, boy.
Okay, I've been...
Alright.
Fuck me, I guess.
What the fuck?
Oh, god.
Oh, I missed.
I missed.
I forgot...
Please!
No!
Oh, my god.
Why is it hitting?!
Oh, no.
It's not hitting, guys.
I... I can't.
I can't.
I...
I need to put my son up for adoption.
I'm not okay.
I need...
I can't.
Guys, does everyone...
One little guy up for sale, guys.
Would anyone like to adopt him?
Please, I need a...
Oh, my god.
I thought I had my axe up.
Alright.
Open your mouth.
What?
Why is it not working?
It's not working!
Why isn't it working?!
What?!
What am I doing wrong?
I don't understand.
Just... Just step on me.
Just...
Alright.
Where is my axe?
Where is it?
Oh, I see orbs!
I see orbs!
There we go!
No, where's my axe?!
I was like, where's my axe?
Where is it?
What happened?
Oh, my god.
It like disappeared.
I was trying to find it.
I was trying to find...
I was trying to find my axe.
You don't understand.
No, are you serious?!
Are you fucking kidding me?
You used it twice?!
Come on.
Oh, my god.
I dodged the wrong way.
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh, my god.
I hate you.
No, I dodged the wrong way!
I dodged...
I can't believe it.
How did I do it twice?!
I can't believe I dodged it.
Oh, god.
You deserve that.
You fucking deserve that, Arteus.
No!
No, I didn't mean to!
Oh, my god, I didn't mean to!
Okay, I'm not angry anymore.
No, are you serious?!
Okay, yeah, guys.
I don't need type advantage.
Okay, maybe I do.
Maybe I do.
I hate my son.
I hate my son so much.
Guys, I hate him.
What was I hate my son?
Wait, I can't...
Wait a minute.
I can't use the chaos.
Oh, you can't use it.
I thought you can.
It's fine.
We don't need type advantage.
Type advantage is for losers.
Is this Pokemon?!
This isn't Pokemon?!
I'm here to be a fucking man!
This is not here for pussy!
Oh, shit.
I'm sorry.
Hurry up.
Really?!
Oh, no.
Okay, look at me.
Look at me.
Look at me!
I might be dead.
There's no way.
Oh,
my God.
I have a shield.
Oh, my God.
I could block the rain.
Guys, I remembered I had a shield.
Okay, we got...
Every...
It only takes me a couple hours to remember I have a shield.
It takes one boss to make me remember my shield.
There we go.
Guys, I remember I had...
Now, this fight seems a lot easier now.
It only takes me, like, a couple hours to remember the shield.
Guys, I have to fight another fucking troll, guys.
Okay.
Troll...
It's different when it's a troll.
It's so different.
Oh, my God.
I hate that attack so much.
It's actually...
It's so cringe!
It's actually so cringe!
Oh, my God.
There we go.
What?!
Ugh!
Get down!
No one loves you!
Your mom hates you!
You're abandoned as a child!
Alright, nice.
Alright, we gotta wait.
Nice.
I hate that move so much.
There we go.
He should die now.
See, I told you guys.
We don't need type advantage.
She's going in!
Alright.
Rare enchantment.
Get this.
Alright.
The rare moments where I remember I have a shield.
It only takes one boss fight.
It makes a lot more sense.
The boy was actually useless during that entire fight.
This is outrageous.
It was unfair.
I was expecting my rivals.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Should be full HP now.
Like, he did nothing during that entire fight.
Your existence was actually meaningless.
Alright.
Gotta get this.
Get over here.
You're the one thing you're good at.
Like, he didn't even...
I had to kill him.
I had to fucking kill him.
What did he do?
He just watched me with his little bow that did zero damage.
I invested in your bow college.
I expected results.
Alright, nice.
I got a new... Oh, whoops.
I should put that on.
Actually.
Where is it?
No, that's the tunic.
Oh, it was this one.
Nice.
Oh, I can add sockets to it.
Add damage.
Oh, okay.
Increase damage of all astros by 6%.
Stacks up to 18%.
Um...
Okay, let's get this one instead.
Do I have runics for other stuff?
Oh, I do!
Might as well, right?
Sometimes I use the astros.
And it's purple!
That means it's good.
Alright, we go this way.
Um...
What?
What did you say to me, boy?
Pick it up.
Pick it up!
That's right, don't you whatever me.
That's fucking right.
Don't you fucking whatever me, boy.
Why is boy a sociopath?
Continues the verbal abuse.
It's making him stronger!
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh,
nice.
Okay.
Oh, I keep forgetting to put square instead.
Um, does this cover up?
Why are the better armors covering up the nipples?
They should be running free!
Oh, hey, there's a dwarf.
Oh, do I have any upgrades?
Guess that's it, right?
Oh, I could upgrade.
Wait, you guys were saying one of my, uh...
One of my attacks is really strong.
We only have axe attacks, though.
I thought I had one for the chaos.
Oh, no.
I don't remember.
It was the... yeah.
What is it?
Can I upgrade my runic?
I don't remember.
Oh, it's through the skill menu.
Oh, okay.
What's in here?
Whoa!
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
Okay.
Okay, that's what's in here.
Oh, my god.
Okay, it's time to be angry.
Sometimes they're not bad things, okay?
Sometimes when you... oh, wait.
That guy is level seven.
He's purple.
I'm a little...
I'm a little worried, guys.
He's purple.
Wait, he's dead.
Wait, what?
Wait, what is hitting me?
Oh, it's these guys.
Oh, no.
Okay, this is a little bad.
I'm getting frozen, guys.
Oh, fuck off!
No!
Oh, no.
Guys, I'm a little...
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Boy can do it.
Just keep locking, boy.
It's fine, just keep...
It's fine.
Just keep locking.
You got this, boy.
Here we go.
This is investment.
Oh, nice.
We did it.
Watch him stop attacking me.
Oh, so easy.
Nice.
Wait, there's more to the hole?
Oh, I don't feel so good, though.
I absolutely do not feel so good.
Nice.
I unlocked the realm of Nifflim.
Now, is this a good hole?
Yay!
It turned into a good hole!
Alright.
Good hole!
Yippee!
Don't you love it when the holes turn out to be good?
Just gotta get rid of the bad stuff first.
Okay.
I'm gonna burn this.
Up I go.
Alright.
Up I go again.
Aww.
Respect your elders, boy!
What if I go the other way?
What's up here?
Whoa.
Guys, my boy isn't respecting elders anymore.
What is over here?
Have I been here before?
I must have.
This must be like a shortcut.
Boy, don't make me burn out the belt!
Alright,
we go this way.
Oh, this is where...
Oh, we can make the portal now!
We have the gem for it.
Alright, we have fast travel too.
Pew!
Alright, now we can just walk up.
Hey boy, I thought you were a god!
Why don't you climb this yourself if you're so fucking strong?
That's right, you can because you're a little bitch.
Boy, put it in!
Why is it with blood?
I thought it was a rock.
Boy, where the fuck did you get my blood from?
Wait, you wrote that in blood?
Oh my god!
Boy, okay.
Okay.
I'm a little worried.
Boy has blood on him now.
Boy started writing things in blood now, guys.
I'm a little worried.
What?
Oh, there it is.
There's more?
Pew!
Oh my gosh!
Boy, that's cool.
A bridge appeared.
Huh?
Oh, she's bolder!
Are you
kidding me?
Nothing has changed since learning that you're a god, boy.
You're literally the same guy.
Oh my god!
He's now way more unlikeable.
That's true.
Get out of here, boy.
Oh no,
he's getting angry.
What?!
Okay!
At least, like...
At least, like, he was born out of love.
Your mom did not love your dad.
Oh, shit!
Like, what was the plan, Artreus?
You shot me?!
What?
I shouldn't even save him.
The fuck?
Where did this dragon come from?
Whose dragon is this?
Is yours?
Oh, shit!
Oh, that boy's got a...
That's fucking right.
Get out of here!
Oh, the eye can...
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
I shouldn't say that.
I'm sorry.
I got way too...
I got way too Kratos there.
I didn't say it, guys!
I... Sorry.
My... I...
I got way too immersive, guys.
Sorry.
I wonder where he's gonna hit me.
Whoa!
I wonder where he's gonna hit me, guys!
Oh, shit.
This guy went...
Alright, don't worry.
There we go.
Me first!
Alright.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
I need to remember the timing.
Guys, this is such a...
...dumb fight, I'm gonna say it.
This fight is so fucking stupid.
Alright, get out of here, get out of here.
Oh my god, you're just gonna be fainted there?
Bro, he hit you once and you're just gonna be...
You're just gonna be knocked out.
Yeah, I'm fucking god my ass.
I literally took a giant... I'm taking a down fist right now on my face.
But you get hit one time, Artaeus.
One fucking time!
I got stabbed too!
Oh, this poor dragon.
Oh, that's... Is the dragon okay?
That's how physics work, guys.
Oh no, not the dragon!
Dragon!
No!
Oh my god, I hope the dragon's okay.
Oh yeah, I have a son too, but...
Hey, frog.
Parried the earth.
Is the dragon okay?
Is he okay?
The full weight of Asgard will come crashing down on you.
It's over.
So be it.
Oh shit!
What do I do?
Baldur!
No!
Listen to me!
What
do I do?
Am I in Helheim?
I'm back in Helheim.
Even in Hell, I'll still beat your ass.
So you'll die here, and then I'll beat your ass again.
I will battle you in Hell.
What?
I'm here.
I like how he sounded so okay.
I'm here, dad.
Here I am.
You literally just survived the fall.
Listen to me and not speak a word.
I am your father, and you boy are not yourself.
You are too quick to temper.
You are rash, insubordinate, and out of control.
This will not stand.
You will honor your mother and abandon this path you have chosen.
It is not too late.
You're still a young boy.
I shall teach you how to be a pussy again.
We are here because of you, boy.
Never forget that.
Yeah?
You're gonna listen to me now?
Oh yeah, round two.
Oh, rescued him yet again.
Alright.
We go this way.
Wait, there's a worse...
Why is there a worse place than Hell?
Wait, what part of Hell is this?
Oh.
Oh shit.
I didn't see him.
Alright, let me go this...
Wait, how do I...
Alright.
How do I get... Oh, there we go.
How do I get to the other side?
Oh, there we go.
Alright, get out of here.
That's fucking right.
Get down!
Boy.
What?
What do you mean?
Wait.
Am I listening to your inner thoughts right now?
Is that your...
Intrusive thoughts?
Boop.
Oh, fuck it.
Alright, come on.
Stop.
Woah!
Where's the third party?
There was only two guys in front of me.
There was a third guy too?
Okay, I did not realize I had the fucking aim, I guess.
Wait, what the fuck?
He made his own shield.
Okay, we gotta kill this one guy.
Alright, I did it.
Wait, how do I open this?
Oh.
Nice.
Huh?
Oh, this is when I killed that one guy.
Happy memories.
Oh no, it's like...
Jekyll and Hyde.
That's his god side coming out.
So nostalgic, guys.
It's like it didn't- It's not like it happened like a couple of hours ago, boy.
That nostalgia is hitting hard.
That there are two wolves inside.
LOL Look,
that was 20 minutes of me.
That's different.
20 minutes of me was so different.
Okay, I got one on the sides.
But, where's the other flame?
Huh?
Huh.
Wait, I can only do one side.
Oh!
Okay.
JK.
Alright.
I didn't see the other gear.
Open!
At least it's not a troll.
You know what the fuck is with those things.
That's right.
I can't beat you, but at least he can because he's a stranger.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Okay, nice.
Okay, I need to get this out of the way.
Jesus Christ, he's so strong!
Why are you so tanky?
Tanky!
Alright.
Use the two wolves inside you!
The two wolves!
Okay, now I'm just gonna let him do everything, I guess.
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Oh my god, I remember that.
I remember that fight.
Oh, nice.
I did it.
Yeah!
Oh, I can upgrade my blade!
Okay, heals...
No flame...
Wait, there's two doors.
Okay, this is the right way.
Then where does this way go?
Wait, what?
Why did I...
What is this pathway for?
Ray, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
What is... Oh, I guess like a shortcut?
Is this a shortcut area?
Oh!
Wait, how do I get there?
What's that for?
Huh?
Okay, open the door.
Maybe I'll figure it out on the other side.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's just another puzzle.
What?
What the fuck?!
Okay, that's not fair.
I literally just got here.
Alright, nice.
Wait, is he still alive?
No, he's not.
Okay.
Alright, time for another puzzle!
I love puzzles!
Yippee!
Now what?
Wait, can I... I don't think that was right.
Wait, what?
How do I move this?
Oh fuck, I went the wrong way.
Move it here?
I'm a little confused.
I don't think I like puzzles anymore.
What?
I can only move it front and back.
Maybe it's here and then I jump from the other side?
Oh, maybe that's why I opened it!
It's not even a puzzle.
I just have to push at the end.
This is not even a puzzle!
I need some bathroom, guys.
I'll be right back.
Okay, never mind.
I guess I don't use the bathroom.
I guess...
I'm just gonna swing this axe.
There we go.
Alright, now I use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
I'm back.
I am back.
Let me check my audio thing.
Oh my god, I didn't realize it was at 84.
Alright, I got myself some water, too.
Mike, Mac, Puddle, Anton, Kaz, Maddie, Duck, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Johnny, Bite, Duck, Allen, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Well, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I just got my YouTube joke in the mail, so excited.
I'm so happy!
A lot of my...
A lot of people are getting their...
Getting their merch now.
Like the limited bundle and the YouTube stuff.
So it makes me so excited.
That...
Everything is sort of getting fixed now, merch-wise.
There's still a few more things to fix at the moment.
But like, you know, we're getting there.
We're fucking getting there.
Things are looking better now.
Baldur?
Where is he?
Where the fuck do you see him?
Alright, get on me, boy.
Is that his mom?
That's right, live through your trauma.
But you can live forever.
Wait,
he can't even...
Oh, nevermind, he might as well be dead.
Do you not hear that?
He can't even fucking bang!
There's no backsies.
That is worse than death.
Bro, like...
He can't even...
Is he like, posturing a fucking clone?
Oh, what?
Wait, he hit his own mom!
Do what?
What?
Huh?
What'd he do?
Oh, because I didn't... he didn't... sorry, not I.
He didn't kill his mom.
I mean, killing his mom's not gonna fix anything.
You want her alive to find a cure.
Oh, he can't even...
I just realized...
He can't even, like, you know, maybe he does, you know, if he doesn't have the woman, he could, like, self-care, but he can't even do that.
That's sad.
How is he gonna relieve stress?
No wonder you went crazy.
Holy shit.
He's keeping all that inside.
I'm sorry.
Every day is November for him, guys.
Truly a fate worse than death.
Every month is November.
Aw, look at him, he's crying.
It's always November, Baldur.
Always November.
No shit.
She literally said...
She literally said she made his son painless.
There's a chest over there.
How do I get to the chest?
Here?
Oh, this must be where the chest is.
Truly a terrifying fate.
I can't believe his own mom did that to him.
Alright, nice.
More steel.
The original Helicopter Parrot.
Oh my god.
I think it's, like, worse, not gonna lie.
That's, like, the worst type of Helicopter Parrot.
Alright, who wants to die?
That's fucking right, I got you.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, I got you.
I love this move the most.
It's so easy.
It's so convenient.
Oh shit, I don't know why I actually swap weapons sometimes.
Alright, nice.
Oh shit, you can parry?!
That should be illegal!
Okay, nice.
Dodge.
Sometimes I don't- I can't lock in the enemies and it's so fucking tilting a bit.
It's a little tilting.
Get over here!
That's right!
I don't need my blades.
A pure manhood and you're dead.
What?
Dad?
Wait, is that my dad?
Dad, is that you?
You came back from milk?
Did I come from here?
I did, right?
No.
Wait, what?
Why is there two different ways?
Oh my god, my dad came back from milk.
Yeah, but, like, I got confused because there was, like, two different air- What?
Okay, we gotta get the heals in.
Okay, it's this way, but what's over here?
Oh, it's a puzzle.
Hey guys, it's our favorite time of the year!
It's puzzle season!
Can I push this off?
Oh my god!
Yippee!
Puzzles!
Alright, fire, fire, fire.
Okay, if I have to do that, that means there has to be a blue thing here.
Oh, please don't.
Why did I have to cut this area if there's no blue thing?
Where's the blue shards?
What?
Why did I have to cut that?
Oh, I hate this puzzle.
I hate this puzzle.
I hate it.
I fucking hate this puzzle the most.
I hate these puzzles!
Oh my god, wait, where did this come from?
Wait, where did this block came from?
What?
Okay.
And we go up.
This just gives me a chest.
Oh my god, there it is.
There's one of them.
Oh my god, I see it.
I fucking see it.
It's all the way over there.
I got one of the three.
But where's the other two?
Where's the other two?
It's one of the three.
Oh, there's... Okay, two.
Okay, last one.
Oh my god, thank god.
Wait, but how do I get it?
Wait.
Oh.
There's no...
I can whip it, right?
No, how do I...
How?
Wait.
How do I get inside?
There must be a way.
Wait.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's so dumb.
That's actually... I hate these puzzles.
These puzzles are the worst.
These are the worst puzzles.
I'm already blind.
Like, I'm already blind.
Why must you torture me so?
Oh my god, and then you add... Okay, goodbye.
That's fine.
There we go.
Alright, this way.
Okay.
No wonder I'm in hell.
Oh my god, no wonder.
It all makes sense now.
This feels like hell.
Now what do we do?
Let's just burn the bushes?
Is that it?
What?
What do I do now?
Now that my boat is on fire, what do I do?
I'm so cold.
What?
Arteus, are you actually cold right now?
What are you doing?
Why are you looking at your hands?
Are you okay?
Spencer, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
By watching the stream, you're already a dragoon!
Congratulations!
How?
What?
Where's my yellow paint?
Where am I?
What?
Oh my god!
Okay, sorry.
Oh my god, it was like hidden in plain sight!
Why?
Oh my god, I can't...
Where's the yellow paint?
It was hidden!
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
It's like the same color as the rest of the boat, guys.
Because it was designed to fly, this was not.
I'm gonna go get through Titanic.
Is there a Titanic here?
What's going on?
Oh shit, Anta, did you get the ships?
Thank you, thank you!
What do we do now?
Yeah.
Oh no, not another puzzle.
Oh no.
Please.
Oh no, I thought it was over.
I'm thinking, boy!
Oh, it's over here.
Oh, thank god it's over here.
Cut, cut, cut!
Nice.
Watch this.
I don't know what I'm doing, but watch this.
Okay, now what?
Now what?
Yeah?
The wheel?
Oh my god, it's like a hot air balloon!
We're gonna fly!
I made myself a hot air balloon!
God, I'm so smart, and that is why I'm a god.
Oh my god, wait, how do I steer this boat, though?
Oh, I don't.
I just go straight up.
Oh my god, all you do is fucking complain.
Where do you get this from, boy?
All you do is complain, complain, complain.
Okay, I got... Oh, nice.
Legendary enchantment.
God, I'm so smart.
It's like I'm a god.
See how I did there?
I forgot I can grab, like, extra money here.
Uh...
Okay.
And then, boop!
Alright, to here.
Oh shit!
Uh...
Wait, there's stuff here.
Oh no, now it'll never come back up.
Oh fuck, okay.
Uh... I guess I go this way.
Wait, what?
There's like so- Oh wait!
No, it did work.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Okay, and then I didn't need that, but that's alright.
I didn't need that, but that's alright again.
And then I go this way.
Wait,
no.
I didn't do what I was supposed to do.
The fuck was that?
What?
The fuck was- Guys, sorry.
You can see the gears turning in my head right now.
It's going over time.
The little hamster in my head is, like, running as fast as it can.
What?
Look, the hamster- Look, guys, the hamster needs a little break, okay?
Wait, I'm back down here, though.
What?
Oh, I forgot this part!
Okay, sorry.
I forgot step one of this.
Give me a sec!
Oh shit.
It'll be okay.
Sorry, I forgot step one.
I told you they always hide in plain sight!
The fucking wheels!
Goodbye.
Alright, we...
We're gonna get out of here.
Huh?
Is that me?
That's me!
I'm gonna watch history in the making.
Son, it's time to meet your grandpa.
Skies of Helheim.
Oh, there it is!
What the fuck?
Okay, nice.
Nice.
That was pretty easy.
You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's go back to our old ways.
I don't even know which is faster.
Not gonna- Ha ha!
Which way is- It's FPS time!
Nice.
Boop boop.
Alright, nice.
Oh, fuck!
That's fucking right!
I killed my father, I could kill you too.
You're about to become a dad?
That's good, cause I'm a father killer.
I only kill dads.
Nice.
God of FPS.
Alright.
Boop boop boop boop.
Jesus Christ, how many are you guys?
We're literally in hell.
If you die in hell, you never come back.
Oh, shit.
It's okay, I have invisibility frames because I'm doing a finisher.
What?
What's going on?
Wait, how do I free us?
Wait, how do I free us though?
Wait!
Okay, I need you to defend me if I'm gonna do this!
I'm trying to figure it out!
They're boarding!
The pirates are here!
Oh my god, Artaeus!
Okay, pick one!
I either free us or like...
Pick one, Artaeus!
Oh no, I don't know how to fucking...
Oh no, they're coming for my treasure.
Okay, now...
Oh, I had to kill all of them first.
I'm sorry.
They keep saying, they're like, Artaeus, cover me!
So I was like, okay, clearly I can do that now, right?
Can we do it?
Like, context-wise, I thought I was fine.
Alright,
we should be fine.
What the fuck are you doing up there?
Get down!
That's fucking right.
Wait, why do I keep accidentally using...
I keep accidentally using my axe.
Oh, I have to light the fire?
Oh shit!
Oh fuck, okay.
Sorry, give me a sec, pirates!
This is much more important!
Sorry, pirates!
I forgot a hot air balloon needs fire.
Where's the other fire?
Where's the other one?
Give me a sec, I'm lighting the fire!
Wait, what the fuck are you doing to my fire?
Be gone!
Just cuz I discovered fire and you're jealous doesn't mean you can just un-light it.
See, this is what happens when you become famous.
All these people...
They wanna take your...
They wanna take everything from you.
Jesus Christ, I have to light it up again.
Why don't you extinguish the other fire?
Nice.
Yeah, they're fucking haters.
They're just jealous.
Alright, get out.
Alright, gotta go back and light this fire again!
Yippee!
Okay, I don't need your finisher.
The finisher takes too much time.
I feel like I kill them way too fast.
If I don't do finishers.
Oh, we're here!
Oh my god.
Please!
I need to hit him more?
I can put more fire?
Oh my god, it's always this one!
Why is...
Why is it always...
Oh man.
It's always this one.
Oh no, they're gonna turn...
Okay, now they hate this fire too.
Alright, I see you.
I fucking see you.
Just cause I give the other fire more attention!
Alright, nice.
Oh no, it's the other hook.
Oh no, two hooks?!
Did I kill everything?
Well, I think I killed everybody though.
What's stronger than one hook, two hooks?
Oh no, I hate these witches.
I hate the witches the most.
Jesus Christ.
These witches are so annoying!
I think the witches are the most annoying one cause they dodge you unless you use magic.
Unless you hit them with a bow first.
They're so annoying!
I'm gonna punch her!
I treat everybody equally!
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ, I'm gonna...
Fucking...
Doesn't matter.
Doesn't matter who you are.
Everyone gets the same treatment.
Honestly, my favorite move.
Alright, nice.
That's right, these fists are rated E for everyone.
Okay, nice.
Second hook!
Down!
Gender equality.
Do I have to light them up again?
God fucking damn it.
Alright.
That should be good.
Are we there yet?
We there?
Are we finally there, Meemer?
Did we fucking made it?
Did we actually made it?
Oh my god.
Where the fuck are we supposed to go?
Why can't my hot air...
Why can't I add a motor to my hot air balloon?
Oh shit.
You know he's stronger cause he's taller.
Alright, good for you.
Goodbye, but I'm taller.
I'm even taller than you.
You might be taller.
But I'm the tallest.
Wait, I could just do that?
Oh shit.
Wait, wait, wait, I got an idea.
Guys, watch this.
Wait, no, that's the wrong one.
No!
I fucking...
Wait, wait, wait, watch this though.
This is gonna look...
This is gonna be so cool.
It was worth...
That setup was so worth it though.
Okay, not gonna lie.
That setup was worth it.
Got him.
It took me three...
I don't understand why he couldn't see it from a mile away.
It took me like three tries to get it right.
Okay, I can do it again too.
Oh shit.
God damn it!
Alright, nice.
Wait, is that another big boy?
Wait a minute.
Wait, wait a minute.
That's another big boy.
No!
God damn it!
Oh my...
Oh fucking Chorus.
They're like, you know what we haven't seen in a while?
A fucking troll.
Like...
Of course.
It's been a while since we've seen a troll, guys.
Oh man.
That's what I miss.
Oh hey.
It's been one hour.
We haven't seen a troll yet.
It's troll time.
Alright, here we go.
That's fucking right.
Stop hitting yourself.
There we go.
Thank God.
I'm so tired of the trolls.
Wait, what?
Oh, I'm so angry.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, why am I still using my fists?
Oh, there's still people still alive.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, where the fuck?
How can I not climb up?
Trolls, ogres, they're all the same.
Dead.
Alright, nice.
Let's grab the loot here.
Gasp.
You can't just, you can't say that, Doki.
Alright.
Go up here.
Come on, lift, Kratos.
Lift!
What did I do?
Boy, come over here.
It's time to experience trauma.
It's the only way to bond.
That's right.
I killed my father and my father killed his father and his father killed his father.
And soon you will kill me too.
Generational trauma.
Gotta keep that cycle going.
Jump!
I love physics in God of War.
Nice.
That was my plan.
Yeah.
I mean, it worked the first time.
If it worked the first time, it'll work again, Meemers.
Shush.
Alright, let's see.
I'm just gonna keep doing it until it works, Meemers.
That's how it goes.
Wait, what?
Ryuji, I'm sad to hear about your graduation announcement, but best of luck to your future endeavors.
We'll support you no matter what.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But what?
Huh?
Did anything happen on Twitter while streaming God of War?
Alright, let's see.
What the fuck happened?
Oh, nothing.
Okay, it's just...
Okay, I was gonna be like...
Okay, nothing happened.
Alright, that's cool.
I was like...
I got a little...
I got a little being like...
Did you have the wrong stream open?
This is what?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I forgot we're in...
Are we in 2020?
Alright.
Let's see.
Oh yeah, I got the loot.
Sorry, he's still stuck in 2020, guys.
He's just a confused Barknight.
Someone's lost in time.
Oh, there is!
Oh yeah, that's gonna be like what happened to Tyr.
What happened to him?
He woke up from his coma in 2020.
Where is he traveling to?
Yeah.
Huh?
That's my symbol!
That's my God of War symbol!
His eyes.
They are jewels.
Like yours.
No doubt signifying the gift of sight the Giants granted us.
Give me a closer look.
Interesting.
What?
Very interesting.
What did he fucking do with his special eyes?
Concealed by Tyr so none could access Baham.
And those few others the Giants trusted.
And right under Odin's nose.
I did promise I'd get you to Jotunheim.
What do you mean, Ed?
You said we were out of options.
Don't you see, brother?
Odin never gave up hope and neither should we.
He knew there was a clue in here, but we are the ones who found it.
These plans are for a key to some chamber Tyr's kept hidden.
I don't know where it's leading or what we'll find, but it's a path.
How do we make this key?
I suggest we ask a dwarf.
The one that my son didn't piss off.
That symbol on the temple door.
It's a bunch of runes together.
Peace, unity, hope, other things too.
Tyr's own design.
He made this door himself.
Things that gods don't do.
No wonder Odin was mad.
Fuck your pots.
Ryuji, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry about that announcement in the title.
Made me thought it was that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
What do your memerize see, memer?
I just thought you were stuck in a coma.
And you just woke up and it was 2020 when you got put under.
What about our trauma bonding?
Thank god my boy got better at lying.
He's growing up so fast.
Oh, I have to...
Oh, am I not back in Midgard yet?
Oh, I'm in Helheim.
I forgot.
Yeah.
Okay, let's swap to...
Alright, I leave Baldur in Helheim.
There's no way he sneaked back in.
Look, I didn't say he's getting better.
I didn't say he's getting better, but now he's actually lying.
So like, that's a little better.
Before he was like, it's all about the truth, but now he lies to my face so he's growing up.
Huh?
Oh, so he can't say what his weakness is.
It's like a blade.
I remember.
Well, I don't know if this follows like the actual Norse myths, but it's like a special blade.
He's a broken AI before AI.
No?
Wait, where the fuck did he come from?
Huh?
What's that?
What is that?
Oh my god, not his hands!
Did you also bend over?
What?
You?
You're fine with working on something that's not a weapon?
Wait, he's shorter?
He can be even shorter?
I thought the other brother was shorter.
What?
I did it!
Oh, it's like his all...
They can work together!
Oh my god!
We brought the brothers back together!
Oh my god, we did it guys.
We accomplished our main goal.
Aww.
Sorry, he's still a germaphobic though.
We did it!
We finished God of War!
Alright, so we got a... Oh hey, blade of chaos upgrade.
Nice.
That's cute.
I'm glad they like...
They work together to help me kill a god.
I like that.
No matter what, at least they have... They unite together on something they hate too.
Oh yeah, we haven't upgraded anything in a while.
Let's see, is there anything?
Oh wait, I can upgrade this.
This is the strongest one, right?
The Hyperion Slam?
Hyperion Slam is the strong one, right?
Okay, I'll upgrade it.
Nice!
Alright, and then I guess I'll upgrade this since I have so much money.
I'll upgrade this.
Wait.
Raw stun damage.
But I'll upgrade this.
I like the wrath of the wolf the most.
The zero vitality run?
What does vitality do?
Oh.
Am I supposed to have more HP?
Whoops.
I was a... Unintentional gaming.
I was just that much of a gamer.
What can I say, guys?
Unintentional gaming.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, upgrade all of these.
Look at that.
I'm such a gamer that it was just that easy.
The game was too easy.
I just had to make it more challenging.
How much?
Okay, I still have a lot.
Let's upgrade everything.
Fuck it.
Am I ready?
Yeah, I can just max everything out.
Like how I maxed everything, but like, fuck this shit.
Wait, I should... Wait, wait.
I forgot.
Wait, I forgot.
I didn't realize my rage has been baby mode this entire time.
Okay.
Let me get... Let me make sure my rage is good.
Let me...
Alright, other than that, none of these matter.
Can't believe I made it this far with the fucked up build I have.
Yeah, that was a different me.
We get what?
Oh, he's gonna cry.
Okay, we go this way.
Alright, we have to go back to Tears area.
It should be this way.
How much do I have left of the game?
I feel like I made so much progress.
I mean, I got out of hell.
Is it here?
No, it's not here.
Not a lot?
There's no way.
I must be getting... There's no way.
I literally... I went through so many character arcs.
There's no way there's not a lot.
I went through so many character arcs for this.
Oh, that's what the keys were.
Nice.
Okay, this hidden chamber.
Yeah, what is this?
Shoot this.
Yay!
Skybridge!
Oh, we are underneath.
Okay.
Oh, that's interesting.
What am I supposed to do here?
Do I shoot this?
What is that?
Hey, what's that?
Yeah, how do I get it?
I'm just walking around in a circle.
Okay.
Wait, where?
Where are you?
Where did my boy go?
Do I have to use an axe on this?
No.
Oh, I have to talk to him.
Interesting.
But can we reach it?
Oh.
Oh, it just opens.
Okay.
What is that?
Huh?
Oh, there's a door?
No, I came from here.
Didn't I came from here?
No, that's different.
Oh.
What do they do?
There's more frost.
There's the snake.
Um, now I have- I brought a woman.
Now an army?
Vikings?
Question mark?
Oh, now I'm on the other side.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Did I miss something?
I thought I was just looking at tapestries.
Did I miss a door?
I got too distracted.
Oh, yeah.
There was a door.
Sorry, I got- I was so distracted.
It was so beaut- The artwork was so beautiful.
I was looking at art.
Can you really blame me?
Oh, is this the portal to Yonheim?
I'm gonna hit it.
Oh.
Um, that was my entire plan, boy.
I'm out of ideas.
Boy, I'm out of i- Oh, sorry, nevermind.
I just- I have to just move this.
What did I do?
What?
Oh, and then we have a different- We have a different entrance way.
And then we have different portals.
Portals!
Oh my god, I- War trolls, but now they're stone trolls.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Huh?
Read.
What's that mean?
Okay.
Did you just do this?
Alright, now we're downstairs.
Oh hey, more reading!
You like that, don't you?
That's your entire purpose.
And being fucking fashion insane, too.
Read.
But she has so many legs!
What was wrong- Are those legs?
Oh my god, no wonder he had so many children.
Uhhh, which way?
I'll go left side.
Oh my god, it's- Oh.
Oh my god, no.
No, not this again.
No.
I- I- I- I don't understand.
Do I have to time this?
Oh my god!
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I fucking figured it out.
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, wait.
I'll wait.
Wait.
Alright.
This is- I'm fucking- I- Ooh, I'm gonna- I figured it out.
I just gotta line it all up.
Hey yo!
Yay!
Alright, where am I?
Okay, I need to grab the heals.
I fucked up the first time.
Ummm...
Okay, I need wind.
Wait, I'll grab this.
So I'm gonna put it here.
Guys, I told you.
It only took me four hours, but my head is expanding.
Oh my god, sorry, that's not what-
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Sorry.
That's not what I mean.
Okay, like I said, it- Okay, I'll- Like I said, it only took me- Okay.
Do we have to put this here?
Jesus Christ.
Put this here.
I- Okay, there we go.
Nice.
Let me grab this first.
Sorry, like I said, it only took me four hours!
And my brain has- It finally started revving up.
I told you guys.
I figured it out.
Aww, it's cutting time.
Yay.
Did I do it?
Oh, I did.
Nice.
Oh, not nice.
Whoa, not nice, guys.
It's fine.
It's fine, I actually upgraded for once.
Oh my god, I'm so much stronger!
Wait a minute.
It's like I should have actually worked on my upgrades instead of hoarding.
Wait, why is this- Wow, it's like this game just got easier.
Is that troll?
It's god fucking- Okay.
I- Okay.
Okay, buddy.
Okay.
I was like, that sounds like a troll.
God fucking dammit.
Alright, there we go.
At least I made it over here.
Oh my god, when is it not a troll?
Why is it always trolls?
Can it be something else?
What if it's- Why can't it be a snake?
A really cool snake.
It's Norse mythology!
It can't all be trolls!
Oh, don't joke.
He doesn't know it was always trolls.
Alright, nice.
Okay, let's grab this.
And then... Why is this their boss music?
I literally just killed them.
Why is there still boss music?
I did it.
What am I supposed to do with this?
Do I have to go back?
Did I finish it too- Oh, it's the tempo music?
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Is there no shortcut?
Do I have to go back via this?
Oh my god, I have to- Oh my god, I have to go back this way.
I have to do the slow way.
Are you serious?
Oh my god, and then he has to fucking try and block the way too.
That's fucked.
Okay, um...
Alright.
Is that a troll that I'm trying to beat up right now?
Is that- Okay.
No, it's not.
Thank god.
Okay.
I was gonna be like, I swear to god, why does he have so much HP?
I was gonna be a little angry.
Oh wait, I should use the ice because he's like fire, right?
That's right, type advantage.
Okay, maybe- I don't care about type advantage anymore.
I- Alright, nice.
Okay.
I wanna use the electricity.
I feel like lightning is stronger than whatever the fuck the blue was.
Nice!
Uh...
Where's the other chain?
It's this way.
Oh, we just gotta go this way.
Oh, whoa, that was close.
Alright.
Chain number two.
What?
Oh.
Wait, that's a wind door?
I was not paying attention.
I thought it was just decoration.
I didn't realize that was an actual door.
I thought it was just a wall decoration.
Uh, I guess I gotta grab- Okay, I gotta grab this then.
Alright.
And then, since we're not coming back anyway.
Oh my god, it is a door!
Door!
Open sesame!
Havoc runic attack.
Wait, but my Hyperion slam is better, so it doesn't matter.
Okay, back here I'll go.
Yay!
Alright, now the other chain.
Open the door.
Open.
Open the door!
Okay.
Oh shit, that scared me.
Wait a minute.
Oh, I can- Oh!
What?
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I can figure this out.
I time it perfectly.
Oh, I'm so smart!
Okay, but how do I- Okay.
Alright, now I got- Okay, wait, I fucked it up.
Sorry, guys, I fucked it up.
That's actually gonna get me killed.
Okay, I gotta modify the one at the end first.
Oh my god.
Okay, where's the end one?
It's this one, right?
No.
Okay, now they're all fucked up.
Whoops.
Okay, that's-
Okay, that's a little awkward.
Okay, I- Okay, give me a sec, guys.
I'm figuring- I'm figuring it.
Alright, now I figured this out, guys.
Here we go.
There we go, there we go, there we go.
And then...
Oh, I figured it out!
Oh, I'm so smart!
I love reforcing things until it works.
Yay!
It always works, guys.
It just always works out.
If you don't understand, just keep trying until it works.
Wait, why is there an explodey thing here?
Wait, what do I- Why is there an explodey thing?
What?
Oh, that's why!
Yeah, it just keeps smacking.
Is that it?
Does it break?
Oh, shit.
I did it.
What happened?
Oh!
Is there more?
No.
Did I get crushed?
Okay, nice.
Aww...
It wasn't that easy.
I was like, oh my god, I feel so smart!
Oh my god, I figured it out!
I'm so fucking smart!
Oh my god, so simple!
Holy shit, what a puzzle for babies!
But I didn't figure it out, guys.
I didn't figure it out.
Sadly, that wasn't it.
So I just...
Oh!
What the fuck?
I just ran.
No!
Okay, I'm alive.
Holy fuck, okay.
Alright, stab this- stab this head.
Yay, we did it!
Is there anything else?
Oh yeah, read this before we summon another fight- a troll fight.
Alright, time to fight another troll!
I love fighting trolls!
It's my favorite time of the year!
Alright, where are the trolls?
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
Oh, okay, clearly I was not ready.
Clearly, okay, clearly.
Alright, I was definitely not- Okay, alright, there's now other stuff I have to- Okay, that's it, I can't be bothered.
I didn't realize there was so much more than this.
So I'm just gonna- oh my god, I'm just gonna keep punching.
Okay, nice.
Nice, we got through the armor, guys.
You heard that?
Oh shit, okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Okay, we gotta get rid of one of them at least.
Oh fuck!
Oh shit, I did not- It's okay, I still have my axe spin.
And I still have this special move too.
And then- oh fuck, okay, that's fine.
Oh, that's not fine, that's not fine, but that's okay.
Okay, that's- I'm just gonna grab this heal real quick.
And then- Oh, nice.
Wait, wait, that's not fair!
Just cause you have a shield over there.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Oh god.
Oh!
It's okay!
Nice.
We did it, not even close.
Wait, I hear more people.
Where is that?
What?
Who are you shooting at?
Oh!
Yeah, come on!
I'm like, what is that sound?
Alright, nice, I did it guys.
I did it by doing nothing at all.
Alright, we just gotta run over.
Nice.
That was a little stupid, but like, hey, I'll take it.
I'll take those.
Oh no, where are they?
Nice, okay.
Okay, they're just mini guys.
It's not a troll.
They can't hurt you, they're not trolls.
They're not trolls, they can't hurt you!
Where is he?
Oh, he's over here.
Okay, I'm like scared I'm gonna get hit by the fire though.
Okay.
Oh no, not you!
Not you!
Oh shit, okay.
Okay, nice.
He can't hurt me.
Oh, I wonder where he is.
I wonder where the other guy is.
Wow, where could he be?
Okay, buddy.
Okay, you just get- Okay, buddy.
There's more?!
Where did he go?
Oh no, not that guy.
Nice.
Alright, I just gotta worry about him.
What?!
He can just do that?!
He just fucking hit through my fucking attack?!
Alright, nice, we did it.
Alright, flipping the temple!
Is it this way?
I don't remember.
It's here, right?
Or was it here?
No, it was here.
It was here.
Oh my god, I'm getting so- I'm actually getting so disoriented.
They all look the same to me.
Where's my boy?
Boy?
Flip the temple!
It's time to flip the temple!
Oh yeah, it's the double tap shield!
I keep forgetting to double tap.
Yeah!
We can work together, guys!
We can do it!
I believe.
I fucking believe!
It can't be that difficult.
Alright, oh I have- Okay, I have the stronger one now.
Alright.
I can upgrade the...
What was it?
Oh yeah, throwing a rock.
I'm gonna learn how to throw a rock.
Alright, time to flip the temple!
Here we go!
Come on!
Push with your legs!
That's so cool.
That's so beautiful.
Oh my god, get rotated!
Get grappled!
Root force is always the answer, Meemer.
There!
On the left!
I think we can climb back up to the realm trap over there.
See that, Meemer?
Nobody can do all this alone.
All these obstacles are just chances to prove we're the ones who can beat them.
We may argue.
Me and Father.
You and Freya.
Brock and Sindri.
But when we all work together, we do make a good team.
And that's Tyr's test.
That's why we're gonna make a team.
Do you hear that, brother?
Lad's found his equilibrium.
What's that mean?
It means you speak wisely, Atreus.
Oh my god, you're becoming smarter, Atreus!
You're doing it!
You're using your brain!
I'm so proud of you!
Oh, I shouldn't say that.
Then he's gonna think I am.
Wait, what?
I can touch it now.
Boy, get over here.
It's time to touch this.
Wait, where did my boy go?
Wait, where is he?
Okay.
I don't wanna inflate his ego, guys.
I can only say I'm proud of him when I'm on my deathbed.
It has to have a built-up.
Only on my deathbed shall he know I'm proud of him.
What have we got?
Some sort of travel stone.
What is that?
Oh, is this the Stone of Yodaham?
Great Ardum Lazarus, that's the Unity Stone.
You know it?
I wasn't sure it existed.
If Tyr possessed this, that explains how he could visit all the realms.
How did he get it?
He held this.
In the panel at Odin's library.
Yes.
Yes, that's it.
I understand now.
It shows Tyr walking the realm between realms.
You know how he must never stray from the path.
Well, Tyr always followed his own path, if you catch my meaning.
So he made his own path.
With the Unity Stone.
Alright, let's use it.
Let's go to Yodaham!
So you're saying Tyr's shrine shows him stepping off the branch of the World Tree.
And you're thinking, to reach the secret path to Yodaham, that's what we need to do?
I am.
How do I use it?
That is what you're thinking, isn't it?
But how do I use the stone?
You need that alchemist for something.
Oh, here?
Wait, is there anything I can buy?
Okay, I just want to make sure I don't have anything to upgrade.
I guess not.
Oh, here's the last item.
Oh, there's the item I lost from...
The one troll... the other...
There's so many trolls, actually.
Which troll, Doki?
You've killed so many!
You gotta be more specific on the trolls!
Alright...
Let's see...
Can I travel there yet?
Where am I supposed to go?
Huh?
Here?
The Realm Between Realms?
It says this.
Anywhere?
Oh, I can pick anything?
Oh, it's... Oh, it's the Realm Between Realms.
Oh my God.
He literally said...
Dear, walk the Realm Between Realms.
Oh my fucking God.
Cause he made his own fucking...
Oh my God.
He made...
I'm making my path right now.
Sorry, I...
Sorry, I was in a coma for a second.
I got in a coma for a sec.
My hamster died on the wheel and I had to get a replacement.
Sorry.
My hamster died, guys.
I had to... That's why I couldn't figure it out.
He left his like... He left his records and my other hamster was reading through the records trying to figure shit out.
Oh yeah.
Oh, that's cool.
I mean, that's pretty interesting.
Oh my God, I already figured this out.
Why does he need to test me?
I'm already... Oh, I'm gonna use the bathroom before I do a stupid test.
My new hamster is still going through orientation.
I'll be right back.
And I'm back.
I'm back, guys.
Alright, let's go.
Let's do a stupid test.
My hamster is ready.
He's gone through orientation.
He knows what to do now.
What's this?
Alright, I'll grab one of the rage one.
I don't need the heals yet.
Alright.
I'm ready for my test.
Truly, it's just multiple questions, right?
I mean, like multiple choice, right?
Oh no.
What happens?
Maybe it's just multiple choice.
What?
Oh, it's just... Oh shit, whoops.
Oh wait, these are easy.
Wait, these are babies.
That's your fucking test?
This is for babies!
Oh shit, wait, he hit me.
Oh my god, I don't know what's going on.
There's way too many enemies, though.
There's way too many enemies around me.
They just keep coming and they just keep coming and they just keep coming and they just keep coming.
Nice.
Alright.
That was so easy.
Oh, are there gonna be trolls?
It's a gauntlet?
Oh my god, you know what that means.
What the fuck?
Oh, they're the...
Okay.
Oh my god, it's... Okay, they're the...
They're the elves!
Oh my god, it's been so long!
I almost forgot you guys existed!
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh no, he hit me, I can't see shit now.
I can't see shit.
Wait a minute.
No, that's all I wanted!
Okay, whatever, fuck it.
That's right, I'm just gonna beat you!
Fuck it!
The best way to kill a fucking bug is to punch it to death!
That's the only way!
Alright, nice.
Jesus Christ.
Oh no.
No, I can't see again!
Oh no, this is not what I wanted.
Oh, I can't see!
No, I didn't want to kill this guy!
Oh, I missed.
Whoops.
Oh, he'll be fine!
He'll be fine, he can't die!
I can't see though.
Oh my god, but I can't see!
Jesus, I hate this.
I...
I can't, I can't, I can't!
Oh my god, I can't, I can't!
It's time!
Oh, it's time!
Oh, no!
I kept getting hit by the...
Oh my god, I can't deal with this shit.
I hate DLs.
Jesus Christ, I'm just gonna...
Oh my god, I'm...
He dodged the...
Okay, what a fucking waste.
I can't believe he fucking dodged the rock.
Like, what's the point?
He actually...
He dodged the fucking rock.
Okay.
Oh my god, are you fucking serious?
Where are you?
Where did you go?
Oh, no.
That's... okay.
That was so risky, I couldn't tell if that was actually him.
Okay.
Nice.
Again?!
I hate you.
I hate you so much.
Oh my god, I hate you.
I can't see you!
Alright.
Are you the low HP one?
You are, thank god.
And they get harder, right?
Oh my god, again?!
You fucker!
Oh my god, I can't see!
Oh my god.
Bro, I hate... oh my god, I hate these guys.
I hate these guys.
I actually hate these guys so much.
Okay.
That shit...
Are you serious?
Okay, I was gonna say, that doesn't hit?
That...
Oh my god, are you serious?
I can't, I can't, I can't deal with him.
I can't.
Boy, I need you to find him.
I don't know where he is.
I need you to find him, boy.
Okay.
Use the walls, use the walls!
Oh no, where is he?
Where is he?
No!
It's fine!
Okay, no.
No!
Just shoot him!
Yes, you are.
You were born ready, boy!
Yes, you are!
You're so ready!
You know what?
I'll just let him...
Oh shit!
No!
Oh my god!
I seriously...
I fucking...
Okay.
I can see now.
I can see!
I can...
Oh no!
No, no, no!
He does so much damage!
Jesus Christ!
Okay, this one...
This one was hard.
Oh no!
Please!
Okay!
It's a lot better!
It's not the L's!
Thank god!
Okay.
They're not the L's.
That's fine!
Oh!
Nice!
I figured it out!
Guys, I learned!
I told you I could learn!
Oh!
Whoa!
Okay, nice.
I still have a power move.
That's good.
I...
Where am I?
I can't tell!
Oh my god!
Where am I?
I actually can't tell where I am!
Please tell me there's heal somewhere!
Oh thank god, there is.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Wow.
I still have axe moves though.
Nice!
Alright, good.
Last guy!
Woo!
Use your bow, boy!
Good!
And use your body!
Oh!
We did it!
We fucking did it!
There's more?!
Oh my god!
I know what that sound is!
I...
Oh!
You know what's better than two trolls?!
Three trolls!
That's a king!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
That's a king!
Go!
Three trolls!
Oh my god, I love it!
Troll numbers 51 and 52!
Oh my god!
It's my favorite!
Thank god!
Always has been!
Doki!
Oh my god!
Jesus Christ!
Oh shit, that's not what I wanted to do!
I hate these trolls!
Run!
Okay.
Alright.
We got this.
Oh wait, he's a fire troll.
I don't know what I'm doing here.
But it's okay, I still have this attack too.
Go!
Nice!
Okay, he's almost...
He's so low!
Get out of here!
That's fucking right!
I was molded by the trolls!
A slasher attack that protects Kratos.
What am I using right now?
Okay, my one...
The one I have right now is so much better.
Okay, did I do it here?
Did I do it?
Did I pass the test?
Am I worthy now?
I can't put the L's where the heart is.
Oh my god, that blind was so frustrating.
I'm pretty sure there was an easier way to fucking kill those L's.
But I'm too stupid to figure that out.
I'm gonna make sure I'm full HP.
Is that it?
Do I just leave?
Oh, I just leave.
Okay, I did it.
The giants secretly possess some remnant of primordial Yotnar creative essence.
The stuff all realms are made of.
The unity stone must have been fashioned from that essence.
To trust an outsider with it, even Tyr, tells you just how desperate they were.
Tyr's braziers, a symbol of the light that binds all realms together.
Why would he use those strange runes though?
Now you mention it, he wouldn't.
Oh.
Then who put it there then?
If it wasn't him, who could it be?
I'm gonna go this way.
Holy shit, that was hell.
That was absolute hell.
Those L's, those fucking L's.
Just wanna be sure if I have any upgrades.
Am I gonna find better armor or should I just upgrade stuff now, guys?
Cause I have a lot of money.
Oh, okay.
My armor can craft?
Woah!
I'm broke.
Sadly, I do not have the money.
I am poor.
Guys, we don't even have a home, guys.
I am very poor.
Oh, I should make him armor.
Wait, did I never give him armor?
Oh my god!
Wait a minute.
I just realized I never gave him clothes.
I never!
Whoops.
That's awkward.
Alright, there you go.
I never actually gave him clothes, guys.
But that's okay.
I learned.
Alright, I'll just upgrade this then.
I have the money, so I might as well.
I mean, it's purple now, so...
Eh, might as well.
Um...
Is that it?
Can I have a better pommel?
I feel like I haven't found a better one.
This is what, level 2?
Yeah, I haven't found a better pommel.
Wait, what?
Yeah!
Okay, uh...
I guess I should buy a better one.
Um...
Grant health burst on any successful precision throw.
On any successful executioner cleave.
The Elite Grip of... I should get that one.
Might as well get that.
Oh, and then...
Okay.
I feel like I'm always... I can get...
Oh, whoops.
That was a waste.
Let's upgrade.
Oh, I don't have...
World Serpent?
Snake Fragment?
Okay, we don't need that.
Alright, final...
I don't even know if it's final upgrades, but I might as well...
No wonder you did nothing.
Oh my god, whoops!
Oh my god, my son was so weak.
My son really was really weak.
Whoops.
Did not realize how weak my son was.
That is awkward.
That was very awkward.
But at least now I do.
Now I know.
Guys.
Now I have learned.
Alright.
Jotunheim, let's go!
It only took me 80% of the game to figure that out.
The next...
Jotunheim is the last section, right?
It only took me the last chapter to figure out about buying clothes for my son.
That's really it.
As long as I did it, it's fine.
I still did it.
Great, thank you.
I know, it was great parenting.
Wait, why?
What did I do wrong?
Huh?
Me too?
Oh my god, we gotta kill Odin?
Yeah, what did we do?
Oh my god.
Why didn't they say anything?
They saw me carry a head around for like four months now.
And they didn't say anything about maybe perhaps knowing where the fucking eye is?
I never asked.
Oh, so true.
You're so right.
I never fucking asked.
Oh, does he have it?
Huh?
Oh.
What?
What was the statue?
Oh, it's the Thor statue!
Oh, so it's in my snake.
Oh, so I have to be inside him.
It's time to get void, boy.
Have we ever got void before?
Alright.
Huh?
Alright, boy.
It's time.
There's always a first time, guys.
Where is the snake?
Oh, there he is.
Mr. Snake, my boy has something to ask you.
Here, I'll go up though.
My boy is ready for his first time.
He's gonna become a man today.
The first step is to get void.
Toki, please.
Oh my god, you're right.
It's the year of the snake.
As per tradition.
It only happens every couple of years.
I'll pay you to never say those words again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, guys.
Happy Lunar New Year.
As per tradition.
Remember this day.
,,.
As you go inside the snake's mouth.
Oh my god, I'm ready.
It's like a theme park ride.
You don't have to get void.
What a way to celebrate.
It's the year of the snake.
Of course I'm excited.
We can only do this once every couple of decades, guys.
You know how long it takes to get to the year of the snake?
It follows the... it's a cycle.
You know how many animals are in the fucking Lunar New Year calendar?
You only get to do this once every 12 years.
Guys.
As per tradition.
Alright, guys.
Before you go into the snake mouth.
During the year of the snake.
You gotta be like...
,,.
Alright,
where's my red pocket, snake?
Where's my red pocket, snake?
They say that once you go inside the snake's body.
You will be rained by a million red pockets.
Look, see?
It's also red for red pocket.
Where is the money?
Wait, wait a minute.
Did my boy just say I used to dream about being eaten?
Oh my god, I'm unlocking something in him right now.
Alright.
When does the magic start?
We're here.
If you don't appreciate it now, you'll never appreciate it.
You'll never be happy.
Oh hey, what's in here?
I got him, it's working!
My red pocket, look at that.
There's another red pocket right here.
Oh my god, I told you.
I told you guys.
Oh my god, is that a red pocket chest?
Oh my god.
Welcome to the year of the snake.
Thank you, Mr. Snake.
I told you guys.
Now we're gonna be so lucky and prosperous for the rest of the year.
Snake related, M color blind.
Is this red?
Thank you for the super chat, Solid Snake.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Auntie Snake.
Oh my god, Auntie Snake got me...
Got me so much gold.
Oh hey, frog.
Wait, no, lizard.
Dead lizard.
Wait, what am I supposed to do here?
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Roku, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for gifting a ship.
Wait, I was supposed to go here.
The fuck?
What do I do?
How do I get across?
Oh, it's here.
I didn't see it.
It was not yellow enough.
CB, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Pinocchio changed since the last time I watched it.
What was closer?
How do I get out of here?
What?
Did I fuck it up?
Not gonna make that.
What?
How am I gonna make it?
So confused.
What?
Oh.
Sorry, it needs to be yellower.
Okay, that makes more sense now.
There we go.
Sorry.
It's really hard to see yellow in a giant red pocket.
Alright.
There we go.
Oh, we go this way.
We go this way.
Wait, where do we go?
Where is it taking me?
Oh, we go this way.
Alright, up we go.
Wait, where did my boy go?
Oh, he's not gonna...
Oh, he's gonna magically teleport, right?
Where did he go?
Is he gonna climb up here by himself?
Oh, there he is.
Good job, boy.
Oh.
Wait, more chests.
What's in here?
There's the eye.
What the fuck?
That's huge.
Looks like it's bigger than the eye socket.
Oh, wait.
We can take this home.
Yay!
Yippee!
Alright, time to roll back outside.
I'm gonna say thank you, Snake.
Wow.
It's nice that...
It's actually nice that, like, there was nothing in the way for this.
Isn't that great?
Nothing get in our way.
Just me and the boy inside a snake.
Alright.
Ah!
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Okay, that...
Maybe he...
Okay, maybe he had a little burp, guys.
He had a little burp.
It's okay.
No, no, nothing is wrong.
It's just indigestion.
Just a little indigestion, right?
What the fuck is going on?
What's going on?
Wait, who's hitting him?
Who's hitting the snake?
Heartburn is rough.
Look, it's just heartburn.
Don't worry.
Oh no, don't fall into that juice.
Use the shield!
That's alright.
You're a god.
What happened?
Wait, what?
What's going on?
Wait, no!
What happened?
Snake?
Freedom.
Wait, is that Odin?
Oh no, it's...
Witch.
Oh, he's close.
Wait, he got out of Helheim?
How the fuck did he leave Helheim?
We know what you are, you fucking witch.
We know what you are.
You made my boy into a street witch streamer.
Oh, there he is.
Before I had to beat some sense into him.
You witch.
Any idea?
Any idea at all?
What you have cost me.
This is like Godzilla.
Mother.
I'm here.
Don't run away.
I'm not going anywhere, mother.
Oh, it's like a great family reunion.
I know that how you feel hasn't changed, but I want you to know...
How I feel?
How I feel.
Oh, Freya.
You said the F word.
Oh, that's a trigger for him, Freya.
Poor choice of words.
I rehearsed everything I ever wanted to say to you.
Every word.
To make you understand exactly what you stole from me.
But now...
I realize...
I don't need you to understand anything.
I don't need you at all.
Back off, Kratos.
This has nothing to do...
This path you walk...
Vengeance.
You will find no peace.
I know.
You...
I'll deal with you later.
But family first.
This again?
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck!
I forgot how to deal with him!
It's alright!
Oh, okay.
I legitimately don't remember how to fight him.
I'm a little scared, guys.
Okay.
Oh, wait!
Wait!
I was...
That's fucking right.
I just remember him being incredibly fast, so I'm a little scared.
I'm actually...
I'm very scared about that.
He is so fucking fast.
Oh!
That's fucking right!
Don't have my range!
That's right.
I will never stop fighting!
Oh, shit.
That's right.
I got the boy this time!
Okay, I'm not protecting...
Oh, shit!
Okay, but who's protecting me?
Who's protecting...
Oh, please tell him to stop!
Please!
Oh, no.
I won't let you hurt him!
No, boy.
Fine.
Stop!
No!
Atreus!
You're bleeding!
Oh, my God!
Breathe, boy!
Breathe!
Oh, my God!
Bro, help...
My blood.
What?!
What is that?
What?
I can feel this.
I can feel everything.
Oh, no!
No!
My son can feel...
Oh, my God.
He's feeling himself right now.
The small no in the background.
What?
What the fuck?
He's alive?!
That man just started fucking feeling himself.
Oh, the mistletoe!
Oh, my God.
I remember now.
Just let him enjoy life now.
Bro, he has to...
It's no longer November.
Merry Christmas, Baldur.
Merry Christmas.
It's December 1st.
Not so dead.
Well, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Um, you can't stop him!
Oh,
my God.
Where am I supposed to look at?
Oh, shit!
He can feel them!
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit!
Please, let me...
Where is he?
Oh, my God.
This is a little rough for me right now.
Okay.
He's so happy.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I...
Lady, I don't think he wants that.
Lady, he definitely does not want that.
He now knows...
He now knows what it's like.
Oh, my God.
I let go of...
I let go of shield at the last second.
I let go...
It's fine.
Yes, I...
What do you mean?
I just parried.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Lady, I don't think it's me that's being...
Lady, it's not.
It's the other way around, Lady.
Oh, my God.
Don't worry, Lady.
It's definitely the other way around.
He's like, stop hurting my boy!
I'm like, bro, he's beating the shit out of me.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I don't...
Stop hurting him!
As he like fucking pounds into my face right now.
Oh, my God.
I hear you.
Okay, nice.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
There you go.
Stop...
Stop bullying him!
I'm like, you tell him to stop first!
What the fuck?
He hit me first!
That's right.
There you go.
I got the parry in.
Alright.
Oh, God, please!
Please!
Oh, my God, please!
Let me through!
Oh, my God!
Please, woman!
Okay.
Jesus Christ, I am...
I swear to God, lady.
I swear!
He has so much HP!
Please!
Please, yes!
Okay, nice.
Nice!
Oh!
He's just...
Please stop!
Can't you see he's just a harmless baby boy?
You think he was a super chat?
Oh, shit.
This is... This is only a flesh wound.
Atreus?
Oh, no.
Am I soloing this now?
This is bad.
Oh, wait.
No, he still helps.
Thank God.
I was gonna be a little worried.
Oh, shit!
I was gonna be very worried.
Oh, he...
Oh, my God, I'm uncomfortable.
He's way too into this now.
Oh, my God.
Guys!
He's a little way too into this.
I'm just trying to fight, bro.
Bro, I'm just trying to survive, man.
I don't know.
He's like, yes!
Very...
Oh!
Bro.
Bro, that ain't it.
Jesus Christ, I keep like...
I'm like getting the wrong...
I'm getting the wrong...
Wrong target.
Oh, where is he?
Where is he?
That's fucking right.
What?
Are you serious?
Okay.
Nice.
I got that in.
Okay, nice.
Alright, get over here!
Yeah, you feel that?
You fucking feel that?
But not in a pleasurable way.
Like, I need you to actually feel pain.
Like, not...
Like...
No, my baby!
Not the other way.
What?
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
I thought...
Okay, um...
Um...
Okay, now he's trying to do something else.
Oh, what?
I was like, oh, look.
They're having family again.
Bro, he's trying to kill you!
Stay away from my son as he walks to kill me!
Oh, my God.
It's this again.
It's...
It's again.
Oh, my God.
I hate this.
What's up, boss?
I...
Okay.
I'm gonna choke your son in...
Oh, never mind.
Guess not.
We're back to UFC now.
Shoot him in the dick!
Do it!
He can feel it all!
I'm surprised the giant still has his eyes.
Oh, that's cinematic right there.
Oh!
Come on!
This is it!
This is your character arc!
Okay, never mind.
Guess not.
Jesus.
Oh, it's time.
Time to be angry!
Because I have Ragnarok to play.
Because I have to be in a second game, Baldur.
I'm sorry.
Oh, shit.
Wait, no.
That's fire.
Fuck.
Okay, I got confused.
Where is he?
Oh, shit.
Where did he go?
I'm so lost.
True, but...
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
That's fine.
Jesus Christ!
How long is this boss fight?
Where is he?
Oh, there.
Nice.
No.
No, are you serious?
I've got...
There's too much CC!
There's so much CC.
I can't see anything.
I actually can't see anything.
He wants to kill you, lady!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Nice.
Are you serious?
Okay.
That's fine.
What?!
He can just do that?
He can just dodge like that?
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
That's okay.
I think my...
I don't like how, like...
Oh, my God.
Are you serious?
I don't like how it cancels.
Oh, my God.
Jesus Christ.
I need to heal so bad.
Then make him stop!
That's right, son!
2v1 him!
That's right!
That's right.
I don't need instructions on how to beat the shit out of you.
I don't need fucking instructions!
That's right!
Oh, my God!
That's fucking right!
Father and son combo.
Huh?
Oh, my God!
Happy Lunar New Year!
Year of the Snake!
Nice.
Do it.
He's beating father.
Not a threat.
And then I'm gonna walk away and then, like...
He's gonna try and kill me and then I kill him.
I don't need your protection.
I'm so glad I don't say that.
No!
You ruined the moment!
You ruined...
Just kill him.
Help yourself.
Can you mother what I do or say?
You won't...
You won't stop interfering in my life!
I was just trying to protect you!
That's what all helicopter moms say.
I've played these games before.
I know.
But you're free now.
You have what you want.
Try to find forgiveness.
We can build something new.
No,
we can't.
Because I will never forgive you.
You still need to pay for the lifetime that you stole from me.
I have paid.
I thought he could... he's a god.
He has like a millennia to live through.
He's literally a god!
That alone will make you whole.
You've seen me dead.
We'll make things right.
I won't stop you.
I love you.
Arteus does not look like he belongs there.
What are you gonna do?
I love
you.
Why do you even care?
You could've walked away.
The Psygorians...
must be better than this.
Freya...
He chose this.
Why did he choose this?
He just wanted to feel!
I will parade...
your cold body...
from every corner...
of every realm...
and feed your soul to the vilest filth in hell!
That is my promise!
He saved your life!
He robbed me of everything!
What?
What a horrible mom.
You are just an animal.
Passing on your cruelty and rage, you will never change!
And you do not know me.
I know enough.
Does he?
Boy...
Listen close.
I am from a land called Sparta.
I made a deal with a god that cost me my soul.
I killed many who were deserving...
and many who were not.
I killed my father.
That was your father in hell.
Is this what it is to be a god?
Yes, and you shall kill me too.
Is this what it always ends?
The cycle continues.
Sons killing their mothers?
Their fathers?
Yes.
Oh, no.
We will be the gods we choose to be.
Who I was is not who you will be.
We must be better.
Sorry about your dead son.
Okay, bye.
This woman just threatened my life and she's just gonna walk away?
She's just gonna- She literally threatened our lives!
Okay, bye.
What the fuck?
I don't understand.
I know saving her was the right thing.
She seemed all evil at the end.
Not evil.
You killed her son.
Her son.
The death of a child is not something a parent gets over easily.
But he was gonna kill her.
She would have died to see him live.
Only a parent can understand.
So you'd let me kill you?
If it meant you would live.
Yes.
Look, there was no easy choice.
For anybody, brother.
But I think we can all agree you did the right thing.
The world's a better place with Freya in it.
Just...
I mean, I guess...
She'll come around.
Back to Tyr's temple, then.
One last time.
Jotunheim awaits.
One of them had to live and I guess like, you know, Boulder was already too far gone.
Boulder was definitely a little too far gone to fix after that.
Jotunheim would bring his cure.
Lies, I'm sure.
Why did Mistletoe break the spell?
Vanir magic is powerful, but its rules are slippery and elusive.
I'm sure it makes sense if you're a witch.
Oh, but it's also bloody tragic.
Boulder was the greatest gift Odin granted Freya.
The one thing she treasured from their marriage.
She only hoped to spare him pain and spare herself loss.
But such impulses can lead good parents to make terribly stupid decisions.
Okay, that's like... I don't... I think she's a terrible parent.
She was definitely way too controlling.
Like, what?
Spilled nothing?
At all?
What has she done that was good after that?
Yeah, I think saying she's a good parent was a little bit of a stretch there.
I guess like in comparison with all the other gods and all the other gods and stuff, it makes sense.
Yeah, I was like, in comparison to other gods, I was like, I mean, I guess like...
It's not... that's a very low bar.
Oh, he won Freya's trust, and she taught him some of her Vanir magic, another choice she would live to bitterly regret.
Sadly, despite his wise counselor's best efforts to persuade him that peace was the only true path to stave off Ragnarok, Odin never let go of his obsession with your nightmare.
The taste of Vanir magic led him to new forms of experimentation and new levels of depravity.
Oh, man.
That's rough, buddy.
That's rough.
I can't believe Odin love-bombed her.
Is this the right way?
No, I went the wrong way.
It's this way.
Wait, what?
Where is it?
Is it this way?
God, the navigation's a little confusing sometimes.
No, I'm too far... far from it.
No, it is this way.
Yeah, it is this way.
Alright, here I am!
It's time to go to Jotaheim!
Aww...
Okay, I got everything I need.
To Jotaheim we go!
Finally, no more trolls, guys.
We did it.
We made it, guys.
No more trolls!
Aww...
Jotaheim!
I could've went... Oh my gosh, I went the wrong way.
Yay!
No more trolls!
Oh!
It's like my own laser.
Oh my god.
That's cool.
Oh!
Jotaheim!
We're gonna do it!
We're finally gonna use all of this to spread your freaking mom's ashes.
Oh my god.
We did all of that just to spread her goddamn ashes.
Huh?
Oh my god, that scared me.
I was like, who is that guy?
Huh?
The guy's holding it sideways like a fucking football.
Oh my god.
I did all of that.
Just to spread her ashes.
I almost forgot that was the original goal in the first place.
What a journey.
It's time for the victory lap.
This is it.
I'm ready to spread those ashes.
Surely that's it, right boy?
Surely, surely it's gonna be over now, right boy?
Oh my god.
Light mode.
Hello?
Huh?
I can see the highest peak ahead.
Right over there.
Is it really gonna be that easy?
Can we do it, Arteus?
Can we just walk over there?
Oh my god, it's over.
One last try.
What are you doing?
Arteus, you fuck.
Oh shit.
Your dad's having a moment.
Boy, please.
It's called God of War, not Son of War.
Oh, it's back.
My chain's back already.
What the fuck, it just magically appeared back.
Alright, here we go, boy.
We're doing our victory lap right now.
Oh my god.
It's over here.
Every time I see these type poses, all I can think about is the point image.
Did you see it?
Yeah, it's over there.
What are they pointing at?
What?
What temple is this?
What are they all pointing at?
Is
it pointing towards this hole?
Oh.
Breed, boy.
Max?
Wait, is that my dead mom?
Or wife?
Boy, she was a giant.
And by God...
She was beautiful.
Wait, what?
Yeah, how?
Oh, is this a prophecy?
What the fuck?
Wait, what?
Oh, so she knew she was gonna die.
All these drawings.
This is our story.
No.
This is your story.
Huh?
But...
What does it all mean?
That I was not the only parent with secrets.
You didn't know.
She was a giant.
I'm a
giant.
Why didn't she tell us?
She sent us here knowing we would find this.
But... why not just tell us the truth?
Your mother would have had good reasons.
I feel like it would have changed his future if she told him.
Was sent to find...
Her?
Why was he tracking...
Yes, we are.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck is that?
Wait a minute.
Boy, um... we are missing some important information on that end.
Oh, hey, that looks like some foreshadowing over here.
Um...
Hmm...
I feel like something's gonna happen.
Who was that?
Look, it's Mother's.
She was here.
She saw every step we took before we took it.
Like she was always with us.
Watching over us.
Leading us home.
Let's finish it.
Alright.
I'm gonna spread those ashes.
Alright, son.
It's been four months.
We're finally here.
To spread your lying mother's ashes.
Wait, there's a giant hand.
He called him son instead of boy!
Oh my god.
Character development.
Yeah, that's definitely not like a normal mortal's ashes.
I feel like if...
If I burned my wife and her ashes started fucking sparkling...
I'd be like...
She's hiding something.
She was definitely hiding something.
Just...
I just...
I don't know.
Yeah.
Like, huh.
It's weird that her fucking ashes are sparkly.
Goodbye, Faye.
Oh, it's Faye!
I forgot it was Faye.
Where the fuck is the mortal part?
What?!
Oh no.
Oh no, he's gonna...
No, I told him not to...
Different!
No way!
Your powers are...
No!
I told him to be a different god!
I don't...
I gotta grow up to be a fucking freak!
Stop it!
I can't even stop!
His mother and nurse is laughing.
Oh my god, it's Lofi!
I forgot him!
He was super chat everything you think.
It was Virtual.
I can't fight fate.
You have two wolves inside you.
No!
That was Lyra!
I thought it was Metasporical, Loki!
You were the super chat magic thing you think.
So sad.
I thought I raised him better.
I'm so sad.
I thought I did right with him.
I thought I raised him right.
But it doesn't matter.
The prophecy foretold he's gonna fuck animals.
He's not even gonna fuck!
I was gonna get fucked by a horse!
It's not even a top!
Loki, please.
That's a take away!
He heard of my disappointments.
Where am I supposed to go?
It's all so bright!
Don't spoil 2 for me!
I understand if you wanna go home.
But...
The snake verse makes more sense now.
It really was an awakening for Loki and for Shiloh.
That one dead cat thing you were the super chat thing you think.
That's a weird name.
He's like looking at me through the door window!
He's like judging me!
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, guys.
I have to take a picture of this.
Oh my god.
He's like, I told you.
I fucking told you.
Okay,
I have to show you guys this.
It's actually so silly.
I can't.
I fucking can't.
He's just like, I told you.
I fucking told you.
You raised a freak!
A fucking freak!
You raised him like this!
I didn't know!
Doki Abertosh!
I didn't know you would turn out like this!
Okay, it's pretty silly.
It's a pretty silly picture.
Alright.
I zoomed it in a little bit.
Okay, where is it?
Where's the image?
Here we go.
He's like right here.
He's like, I told you.
I fucking told you.
It's like a window door.
He's like, I told you.
I told you he was gonna be a fucking freak.
I told you.
He knew.
He fucking knew.
Wait, where's the dwarves?
Did they just leave you on the ground like that?
In one of the giant panels in the world, it depicts Odin on an eight-legged horse.
It's already been born.
Ruby, thank you for your very first super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
It could've been a prophecy.
You don't know that, Ruby!
It could've been a prophecy, too!
Oh my god!
Oh, we did it!
We finished the game!
But...
But at what cost?
We did it!
That's how I am!
That's how it ends!
I find out you're a freak!
That's how I end
it!
Why does it end like that?
Alright, go back home.
Oh, okay.
Keep going.
Okay, I'm not home yet.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, thank god.
Okay.
Okay, that's not how it ends.
Okay, thank god.
Do I go back to Midgard?
Where is home?
Guys, where...
Do I go back to Midgard?
Okay.
Okay, okay.
That's not how it ends.
Thank fucking god!
I don't want it to end finding out you're fucking lowkey.
Okay, thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Ragnarok.
Don't look at him.
Alright.
Wait, why can't I fast travel?
What the fuck?
Guys!
I have to walk home?!
Oh, no.
No, he's just talking.
Alright.
Alright, okay.
They finished off.
Okay, I thought they were gonna hold me hostage.
Okay, I was gonna be a little afraid there.
Alright.
Okay.
Where was home?
Alright.
Home.
At least...
At least it just doesn't end on that note.
Thank god.
No, we're not doing... No.
We're not doing that again, son.
I take...
You know what?
No, you're...
Oh my god.
I take back, son.
So it's true.
He is gonna get an egg-legged horse.
It was a prophecy!
Why did you do this to my son?
Did I just run in a circle?
Oh, there you go.
Alright, it's time to sleep away the pain.
And it's time to sleep away.
Sleep it all away as if it never happened.
Where the fuck is my door?
Oh, there it is.
I walked past it.
Time to sleep it all away.
Bury everything.
Repress the trauma.
Knowing what he's gonna become.
I didn't raise him right.
I can't stop destiny.
That's the worst part.
But you can't stop destiny.
Door?
Humor.
It looked like he was gonna look like, you know, like he was gonna draw the like, draw the gun.
Oh my god.
We did it, everyone!
We fucking did it!
We beat God of War!
Absolute cinema.
Right there.
Behold the God of Thunder.
I- Oh my god.
That was the biggest plot twist for me.
Finding out he was Loki all along.
I- Oh my god.
I'm so- I'm sad.
I just- Oh my god.
I don't know why finding out he was Loki all along made me so sad.
Cause I felt like, no matter how well I raised- We failed him.
We failed him as a father.
If anybody has the biggest daddy issues, it's Loki.
Loki is like the embodiment of daddy issues.
We fucking failed him.
We- He has daddy and mommy issues.
Like, we-
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I was like, son, as long as you're not a freak- One of those freaky gods that bang animals or do incest, you're gonna grow up to be a good god.
And then- Oh, I was wrong.
I was wrong.
And he's not even banging them.
He's getting banged by them.
Like, what kind of disappointment have I raised?
I shouldn't have taken him to the snake guys.
Why did I encourage it?
No wonder he liked it.
I awakened something in him.
I blamed a month-long abandonment for how he turned out.
CV, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doki, stop.
Is this the only- Yes.
This is the only thing.
Finding out he was low-key all along, it just- Oh, it hurt.
Oh my god.
Oh.
Anyway, that was a fun game.
I actually- The story was like- The story has actually been incredibly enjoyable throughout it.
So like, it's definitely been a very wild ride throughout the last four months.
I like- Some people were like, there's no way she's gonna finish God of War today.
I proved you all wrong.
I knew it!
I knew I could do it!
What's the next series?
Well, the next series is Dynasty Warriors Origins because we have a lot- I don't know how long it is.
I didn't do how long to complete Dynasty Warriors Origins, but that's the next series we're gonna be focusing on.
So, yeah, two lessons down the hill.
But it's been very enjoyable.
I don't think we died in any of the boss fights today.
Oh, is the music very loud?
Sorry.
Sorry, I didn't realize.
Whoop.
I didn't realize the music was very loud.
I hope you guys heard me a little bit.
Oh, okay.
Fuck the credits, I guess.
Present day.
Oh, wow.
Whoops.
I sort of skipped the credits.
Oh, what?
Oh, he had a prophecy!
Oh.
Oh, he- Oh, he had a vision!
It's okay, it said several years.
We still have time.
Oh my god, that was a wild ride.
What an insane four months we were all here.
We finally finished God of War.
Oh my god.
But yeah, we didn't lose to any of the boss fights, I feel like.
We lost to fucking trolls!
And elves!
Goddammit.
But like, for the boss fights themselves, we did really well.
But yeah, thank you all for coming through the journey of God of War.
For those who missed the announcement, on January 24th, I will be streaming the launch of Sinuality Echoes of Ada, and I will be in the game as a cosmetic item!
So on the stream, on January 24th, huge shoutout to Bandai, thank you to Bandai for the sponsor and putting me in their game as a cosmetic item.
I will be giving out codes, I will be giving out a code where you can claim to claim the item.
So you don't have to grind the item out or anything, you can get it right away.
But it will be on the 24th.
I will also be like multi-streaming on Bandai's official Twitch channel, and maybe the YouTube channel as well, and on my own channel.
So my channel will, and it's gonna be on the Steam front page, it's gonna be on the Steam game page, the stream.
So yeah!
Thank you everybody for watching!
I am tired now.
I think we have, I have a Marvel Rivals scrim tonight, so I won't be streaming it, I believe I don't know if Kony is streaming, Kony asked me if he could stream it and I was like, yeah sure.
Cause I know other teams have been streaming their scrims, so it's bigger to be okay.
But I have a scrim in like an hour, I think.
I don't know, I know Kony was asking if he could stream it, so I'm not sure if he's gonna stream it.
But yeah, anyway guys, thank you for being here for the journey.
Just had the biggest plot twist of my life for this game.
Honestly, they felt like they just slipped that in, like, they're like, ooh, your name, it says Loki.
They just slipped, I was like, oh my god it's over, what a beautiful moment.
And then he was like, your name is Loki and by the way, he's Loki by the way.
And it like just, oh my god, it just broke everything in me.
And he just dropped it out of nowhere.
Hey guys, as always everybody, stay hydrated, pause the game and move around and get that blood flowing.
And if you, except for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody, bye guys!
Bye!